And we're live.
Hello,
Michael Shermer road.
You could see with your pile of your
writing,
what could you got?
Their moral arc?
Heavens on earth.
Okay.
You just have to take magazine.
It's the latest issue.
Why is there something rather than
nothing?
We'd like to tackle the little
questions.
That's a deep one.
You've dealt with this on the show.
Yeah.
Too much.
It's a,
that's one that just,
you know,
when you're in traffic and you know,
what is this?
When you have someone like neil or Sean
Carroll or,
or,
uh,
Lawrence Krauss talking about this,
it's like,
Whoa,
I'm not a physicist.
I'm a social scientist.
So for me,
I come at it like,
what do you mean by this word?
Nothing.
Because most of us have this idea of
what I mean.
Oh No.
In physics it means this other thing
like,
okay,
well I think our limited understanding
of what they're talking about.
Like when I see those guys writing down
on legal papers with all that scritchy
scratchy,
crazy looking very fake alien language
and mathematics.
Like,
thank God you guys are out there.
Well,
I opened heaven on earth with.
Imagine yourself dead and you know,
most people go,
well,
you know,
I see myself in the casket and my
friends and family around a hopefully
their morning.
No,
you wouldn't see anything.
Of course you,
you're dead to imagine anything.
You have to be conscious and alive so
you can't even picture being dead.
So he can't picture not existing.
And it would be the same thing.
Imagine there's no universe.
Okay,
I see blackness.
No,
there's no blackness.
I mean,
nothing would literally be not just no
light,
but no,
no perception of darkness,
nothing.
Not even nothing.
I was going through instagram the other
day and there was this one person who
was talking about the purpose of life
and when you die,
what's going to happen?
And I immediately just started laughing.
I'm like,
you don't know how he's saying this,
like when you die,
what happens?
And he was like,
one of them spiritual type characters is
just kind of a huckster,
is a lot of spiritual hucksters out
there these days.
There are.
Yes.
The,
in the nineties we debunked all those
psychics talking to the dead.
That was,
uh,
that,
that hasn't been too popular in recent
years,
but that was a big thing,
but caught onto that little earpiece
thing,
the earpiece or just the cold reading.
I see a father figure as a grandfather,
father,
uncle,
friend of the family,
you know,
you can.
And uh,
he saying something about,
um,
you know,
it's okay for you to forgive yourself.
Oh,
okay.
Well where was the,
will he hid his will somewhere?
Where is that?
Because that's what we want to know is
that ring he had.
Whereas if you're just vague enough,
I mean like horoscopes of you're just
vague enough people who are like,
oh my God,
it's right all the time.
It's always right.
Like,
that's not even a real horoscope.
If you really want to pay attention to
actual astrology that you have to know
the date you were born,
that time you were born.
It's not just the month of August,
you know,
it's like they got to know,
they want to know or evening,
you know,
what do you think about all that stuff?
It's all bunk,
is it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Why has it been around so long?
Well,
because the,
well it's called the barnum effect where
pt Barnum,
you just offer something for everybody.
So if you make a general enough,
you know,
I,
I sent you an intelligent,
wise person that people really enjoy
your company and you like going to
parties and being with other people and
yet you liked the quiet solitude of a
walk on the beach and when people go,
yeah,
that is so me.
Well,
I've pretty much described every
scenario.
You can have your alone,
you're with people.
But it's one of those things where if
you talk to someone who is an actual
believer in astrology,
like they,
they are so convinced.
I got a friend of mine who was trying to
tell me that he makes all of his
decisions based on consulting with his
astrologer.
Well Reagan,
Nancy Reagan for his travel.
After he was shot,
she got real paranoid about that.
Well,
so part of the problem is the
astrologers and psychics are themselves
remembering their hits and forgetting
their misses,
the confirmation.
And so I knew a psychic or a magician
who was working.
The psychic friends network
back in the nineties when it's hard,
it's hard to make a living as a magician
doing kids' parties.
They all want to have their own biggest
show,
but only a few people get that.
So you got to do something on the side.
So this guy was doing psychic friends
network and uh,
he told me all about it.
They gave him a book,
a three ring binder and you know,
here's the kinds of things you should
say and you know,
people are calling for love,
health,
money,
career questions.
So you can spend 20,
30 minutes at three 95 a minute just
going through there.
You know,
I sent you in a relationship right now
and one of these more committed than the
other.
Tell me about that.
Ten minutes later,
you know,
there's still talking and you're
thinking about travel.
You're not happy with your job.
There's some financial stress in your
life right now.
And then he told me about stuff like,
now go get a crystal and then a candle.
I want you to set it up here on your
desk and this would go on and on for
hours and they charge by the hour and
they chose what they are.
So one of the problems that psychic
friend networks had was people were not
paying their phone bills because they
come back on $800 phone.
They would just not pay it.
So the phone companies crackdown down on
the psychic friends network company
going,
hey,
this is getting out of hand that people
aren't paying their bills.
So they had to ratchet it back a little
bit.
This right.
They would do it through the phone.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
They wouldn't get a credit card from
you.
They would just stay on the line with
Right.
So he told me that when he first
started,
he got like sixty cents on the minute a
for three 95 at that per minute.
But then they bumped it up as he got
more experience and kept them on the
line longer.
They gave them bonuses,
now you get a dollar per minute or
whatever.
How is that not illegal?
I mean,
he's not even a psychic,
shouldn't you have to be a doctor?
You have to go and you've got to go to
medical school.
We've got to get a degree.
Shouldn't.
There's a interesting history there
because in New York City for example,
it was difficult to outlaw like the
three card Monte guys on the sidewalk
with the cardboard because it's just
kind of a game right now.
Now it would be illegal to sell
fraudulent stocks or something like that
or sell a product that's advertised as a
health product when it's not,
but if say in that case it's under food
rather than drugs or say no health
products like vitamins are under
different standards than say medical
drugs.
I'm a psychic is more like an
entertainer.
So this is for entertainment purposes
only,
so we can do whatever we want as opposed
to a medical doctorate.
That's dispensing advice.
So in medical doctor is a bad example.
Maybe I shouldn't say that engineer,
but the point is like,
if you're going to work as a psychic,
like on a psychic network,
if you have a business of selling
psychics,
like you should be able to.
You have to exhibit some sort of psychic
something.
Well,
they can't,
uh,
you know,
under controlled conditions they always
fail.
There's nothing that's ever been done.
Now what about the one thing that I've
read that a statistically more people
can recognize that people are staring at
them,
like when they're looking at you from
behind that horseshit?
Well,
it's not been.
It's not been consistently replicated.
So is it possible some people with a
certain sensitivity can detect?
Okay.
So one explanation,
the skeptics explanation is that if I'm
in a say a starbucks or something and I
kind of have a sense that people are
talking about maybe looking at me and,
and,
and I look and that catches somebody's
eye and they turned to me and I think,
oh,
that person's looking at me or vice
versa.
I'm looking at them and then they send
something or whatever.
So there could be some element of chance
to that.
Now I'm the guy that does this,
rupert sheldrake,
um,
you know,
he believes that it's actually some kind
of like a psychic power through the
medium like that when I'm looking at
you,
something's coming out of my eyes and
particularly in your neck.
So that's morphic resonance,
morphic resonance.
Now Richard Wiseman,
a British like experimental
psychologist,
he's tried to replicate that and he
always fails.
And then this other woman,
Marilyn Schlitz,
she also tried to replicate it and she
was able to replicate some of it.
So there may be an experimenter bias.
It's not clear if it's the skeptics that
are biased or the believers that are
bias,
but in that case it's best to just say,
you know,
we don't know it.
So the default position,
the null hypothesis is that it's not
true until you prove otherwise.
And that's a difficult one to prove.
Now if they say,
if I say,
well,
why is the effect so subtle?
Why can't you go to Vegas and become a
millionaire gambling or play the stock
market?
You know,
we know traders just need a tiny,
you know,
one point point,
oh,
one percent advantage over the other
traders,
whatever,
and they can make a lot of times it just
psychic abilities.
Psychic abilities is a very broad term,
right?
It's almost like saying drugs because
like certain drugs that put you to sleep
and certain drugs that make you hyper,
they have very different effects.
So saying psychic ability,
like maybe have the ability to see if
someone's looking at you,
but you don't have the ability to pick
the lottery.
Right?
Uh,
so the hard part in testing psych exist
to pin down what exactly are you saying
you could do?
Right?
And that that's where it gets pretty
fuzzy.
So these like why is it legal for the
phone psychics?
Because they,
you can't pin them down.
If somebody says,
look,
I'm just giving relationship advice,
why is that illegal?
If I say like the Tony Robbins Netflix
documentary,
I'm not your guru,
which is basically I am your guru.
He has that moment in this huge
auditorium.
There's like 3000 people there and he
gets this woman up on stage and she's
got relationship problems.
He says,
do you have your phone feels yeah,
take out your phone and call him right
now.
And she talks her through dumping this
guy onstage on the phone and he's at
work or something.
He's like,
what?
And then she hangs up and everybody's
happy that she did this.
Now is that a good thing or a bad thing?
I have no idea.
It's great for show business,
but what if you know,
so how the fuck.
I mean that seems crazy.
Like how do you know what kind of
relationship they really have.
Now somebody that talked to both of
them,
right?
Wouldn't you?
Somebody that I brought this up at a,
at an event recently,
a party and somebody said,
oh,
I know the backstory.
His staff had been working the audience
and they,
they knew all about her and the
relationship and it was about to go sour
anyway,
so we brought her up.
It's like,
okay,
so this is the thing,
what you see the psychics on tv,
there's a lot of stuff you don't see.
They work the audience,
they know,
people fill out like the psych,
the faith healers,
they fill out prayer cards,
they put their name and address and
their ailment and then,
you know,
the faith healers have a little earbud
in there and they're listening to the
person in the back reading,
okay,
here's the person they have clocked coma
or whatever and you hear him calling
this out.
So,
uh,
so there's a lot of that that we don't
see.
The Anthony Robbins is not claiming any
kind of psychic ability.
He just,
he's just trying to provide positive
path for improving your life.
And if you're in a bad relationship,
that would be a positive path.
Let's get out of that relationship and
then move forward with it with emotion
and power and love and fucking probably
throw a karate kick and get everybody
pumped up and jump around a little Bobby
Brown headphones on.
But he's,
he's a showman too.
Yeah,
that's right.
So,
but,
but my point is that the psychic could
say the same thing.
Look,
I'm just dishing out at.
I don't know.
I mean it,
it's weird to put him in that category,
right?
Because he's just trying to get people
excited.
He,
I think he does some good.
I really do because he did me some good
when I was 21 years old.
I used to listen to his,
I think it was called unlimited power.
I think that was the name of the book
and I listened to it on audio cassette
by the pool was shitty apartment that I
was living in when I was trying to be a
standup comedian and it helped me.
He had some really good advice in terms
of setting goals and in terms of like
the way you approach things and look at
things.
But I agree all of that in any of these
self help books,
Jockos books or Amy Alkon.
There's a lot of stuff that very similar
to what Tony Robbins.
A issues and.
Okay.
That makes sense.
Set goals and be motivated and think
positive.
Maybe air a little bit on the side of
over optimism
so you can push through the failures,
but don't be blind because maybe it's
certain times it cut and run and change
course in your life.
Something like that.
The hard part is getting,
getting is studying that which,
you know,
experimentally which are the best
techniques versus others.
And um,
there was a guy wrote a book called Sham
s h a m self-help actualization movement
and he was the head guy for Rodale press
that publishes these self help books.
Um,
and so his takeaway on in this book was
that the number one predictor of people
who will buy,
sell up books are people who already
bought self help books and they continue
buying them.
So if you say,
does it work?
Well,
it works.
If you work at sort of consistently like
you gotta listen to the tapes like every
weekend or every low moment.
It's not like taking the pill and your
cancer's gone.
Uh,
you have to kind of keep practicing it
as this is a lifestyle change for it to
work.
Yeah.
That's um,
and also what do you mean by work?
So Tony goes into a corporation and they
get a bump a,
this is an example in this book to get a
bump in sales.
So they get the salesmen all motivated,
they hit the phones on Monday morning,
you know,
within two weeks their sales are kind of
back to where they were.
So you get.
So they got to bring the self help guy
back in every month or so to keep them
super motivated.
Well you've got to give them some sort
of incentive to state,
state pumped,
right?
I mean some financial incentives,
like one of those I'm old school
phrases.
The inspiration is like bathing.
It works,
but you have to do it regularly in order
for it to be effective.
I like that.
I mean bathing works,
but it doesn't mean you like hey,
two months later a smell like shit.
It works.
Yeah.
Daily.
You have to do it all the time.
It's like saying why?
Why can't the NFL teams play the whole
game like the last two minutes?
Because it's so exciting.
The two minute drill,
because they can't do it physically.
You can't keep that up.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I think you could physically keep up
that enthusiasm that Anthony Robbins
provides,
but you have to be either you have to
have some sort of an office environment
that is an incredibly enthusiastic to
the point where you guys have engineered
this environment where everybody's
pumped up,
but that's going to be a being that
doesn't leave a whole lot of room for
the individual to be themselves.
I feel like that would be terrible to
work for a place like that where
everywhere you go there's motivational
sayings and people were chanting things
in the hallway and everybody's just got
energy at 10.
It's a Co,
you know,
that's.
That's what a guy like anthony robins
will provide you for a short burst.
We just hope that some of it sticks.
Right?
Well,
this is amy elkanns book.
Unfuck allergy.
It's great,
but yeah,
she calls these small wins or whoever
calls him small wins,
like make your bed in the morning or
shave or whatever,
or like Jockos little twitter posts at
4:30 AM.
Yes.
Now I'm never getting up at 4:30,
but when I get up at 6:30,
we'll occasionally like five this
morning for the morning ride.
That leaves at 7:00 AM.
I get up at 5:30,
so I'm not happy getting up at 5:30,
but I think,
okay,
Jocko has been up an hour.
He's already worked out already done
working out.
Okay.
I can't really complain.
Come on.
Shermer giggling that,
that kind of little thing.
This is Jordan Jordan Peterson point of
the,
you know,
make,
get your life in order.
What is he talking about?
Just stand up straight.
Make your bed,
clean your room.
What's he talking about?
He's talking about these little wins,
like if you can do that,
then the next thing that's a little
harder comes a little easier and also
those things that are in the background.
If you know that your your life as a
master cars filled with fast food
wrappers,
you're,
you know,
you've got that thing that you haven't
taken care of in the back of your head
that,
that will,
that that's going to disrupt.
It's going to be flowing in your
thoughts.
For the most part,
it'll be a distraction.
Right,
so those little things apparently do
matter.
There's a theory of crime called the
broken windows theory that is favored by
criminologists to explain the decline.
The crime decline in the nineties.
What happened in New York City,
they started cleaning up the graffiti.
They started catching the turnstile
jumpers.
They started cleaning up the streets.
They started boarding up.
Windows has no broken windows or
replacing the windows.
The theory is that if there's a signal
in society that no one's paying
attention,
there is no law and order here.
There are no rules or norms.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
You're going to get more crime if you
send the signal through little things
like we're not gonna,
allow graffiti on this wall anymore and
no more turnstile jumpers in the subways
and so on.
And so when,
when that happened,
then there was a trickle down effect and
then crime decline.
So that's the most popular theory for
that and I think there's something to
that.
Yeah,
that makes a lot of sense.
And what they did with New York City is
really fantastic if you,
if you go back to when I was a kid and I
traveled to New York City the first time
when I saw times square,
I guess it was probably like 18 or 19.
I was like,
look at this fucking crazy place.
Like this is madness.
And you know,
you see it in movies and it's just
always this horrific scene.
It's always peep shows and hookers and
pimps and thugs and drug dealers.
And you go there now and it's like a
mall threw up.
It's like a giant neon mall of America
Time Square.
If you took a person,
if you grabbed a guy from like 1988 and
you put them in a time machine,
said,
hey man,
I'm going to bring you 30 years in the
future and you're going to see New York
City the way it looks.
Then like,
what do you expect?
Like,
oh my God,
it's going to be like,
like blade runner.
People are going to be shooting people
and selling body parts and now you get
there and it's like Guy Fieri Aries
restaurant.
And two huge,
gigantic lcd screens and then there's
some people that would long for the old
days,
the dirty seediness Lenny Bruce talked
about,
you know,
and he lived there.
It's like,
I mean,
well that has a certain charm,
I guess if go going into the nightclubs
or whatever,
but the surrounding daytime neighborhood
or something,
you,
this isn't where you want to live rather
live in the vomited mall.
Well,
I'm not crazy about that either,
but uh,
but,
so there's a reason why cities have
certain restrictions on those kinds of
stories coming in in a crappy
neighborhood like downtown,
old town.
Pasadena now is kind of a hip place to
go.
But in the seventies when I went to the
ice house,
but,
you know,
back in the day,
in the seventies,
uh,
just as a spectator and uh,
but it was terrible down there and
wasn't really.
Oh yeah,
it was a dump.
I mean,
there was.
Oh,
terrible.
Yeah,
it was horrible.
The word was,
according to my friend Bob Fisher,
who owns the icehouse,
he said that what it was was in the
early days of Hollywood,
the producers would all buy homes in
Pasedena.
These,
they have these beautiful old estates in
Pasadena,
but the stars would all live in the
Hollywood hills,
so they would all be just boozing it up
and partying down in the Hollywood hills
and the producers like let those crazy
animals go have added in the hills.
We're going to back out a little bit and
they,
they establish that community out there
in Pasadena.
Right?
Right.
So to turn it around,
like one of the key things,
uh,
a mall can do is get an what they call
an anchor store.
Someone like a saks fifth avenue,
somebody that's really respectable,
big.
And then you can call the other guys,
go,
look,
we've got saks fifth avenue.
Oh,
you got sex because they haven't even.
Then I can be next to him.
And then it starts going and then little
by little,
each of them cleans up their
neighborhood a little bit more.
And pretty soon you end up with old
town.
Pasadena,
now,
well I was telling you guys before I had
an issue today where my credit card got
robbed and uh,
you know,
whatever credit card fraud,
someone got a hold of my number,
which is really,
that's the one thing that people worry
about the most about shopping online.
Right?
But I guess that could kind of happen
everywhere,
but you got to think that if there's
anything that has changed malls more
than anything,
it's got to be the ability to just shop
online on your phone like Amazon.
That the fact that they figured that
out.
I remember when Amazon came out and it
was just a bookstore.
I was like,
who the fuck is going to buy books
online?
You can just go to the bookstore.
This is ridiculous.
What a stupid business.
Meanwhile,
that guy has more money than any human
on the planet is poor bastards.
Getting divorced too.
I heard last night that there's a rule
in Washington that everything that you
make as a couple,
you have to split.
We've been together for over 25 years.
California,
California law is.
Yes,
50 slash 50.
Well,
longterm marriages,
20 years or 10 years or more,
it's 50 slash 50 and that includes
downstream income from anything you did
that you're still getting paid for.
Say Ten years ago you wrote a book or
whatever.
Mrs Bezos is getting paid and he's worth
100 plus billion dollar and 37.
They said,
wow,
so she's going to get half of that.
We're probably going to.
Because it's a lot of stock.
They said they're going to have to just
be stay friends because they better be
super nice to him.
Even if he gives her a quarter.
She's like,
I got Rollin got wrong.
The richest people in the world now,
but after all these bookstores,
when a business,
there's some irony that Amazon now wants
to start opening physical brick and
mortar stores.
That is kind of ironic,
but it does make sense though because
there are some brick and mortar stores
and I think that guy's a conquer.
I think he just wants to take over
everything.
Well,
why else would he buy whole foods?
And I was like,
Oh,
the supermarket business,
I can fuck this up too.
Well,
automate it.
He can,
I don't know,
maybe get ordered whole foods delivered
to your house.
I think the,
I don't know if that's available yet,
but I think it is right as an essay now.
Most grocery stores even like all the
Ralphs have home delivery within two
hours to compete with Amazon prime.
Right?
Yeah.
Wow.
Are.
And if they don't do that,
you can just order it online and pick it
up and I'll bring it out to.
I went to pavilion's the other day and
they had a bunch of delivery trucks
parked in the parking lot.
I was like,
look at this,
think of these cool delivery trucks.
Have to have that one store you can walk
in and there's no cashiers.
They just trust that everyone's not
stealing.
And I think they just are comfortable
with a certain amount of theft.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
that's interesting.
Well,
they probably have cameras everywhere
too,
you know,
but it's um,
the online purchasing like that has got
to put,
that must be putting the most,
as far as like the most impact on
stores,
brick and mortar stores.
It's like the ability to purchase
online.
It's got to be devastating for them.
Right?
Totally.
And up in Santa Barbara where I live now
and just riding upstate street this
morning at the end of the ride,
you know,
it's like the third,
maybe a quarter of the stores are closed
out of business empty and you know,
state street,
Santa Barbara,
this was like the happened in place to
be and I and a real estate friend of
mine says,
Oh,
well let's see that story there.
That's $22,000 a month to lease.
Like,
Whoa,
okay.
So you have to.
Then you have to have a retail outlet
that's really turning over the customers
and there's a lot that just can't do
that.
I mean you can't have an antique store
that's going to do that are a little
knickknack store.
Santa Barbara is one of my favorite
places and it's really interesting
because it's a,
it's a small area,
like I don't even think there's 150,000
people less than it is about 90,000.
Is it Montecito included or with
Montecito included?
Galito Gilead is like another 30,000 or
so below that.
You have carpenter Ria,
that's like another $20,000 or so,
so yeah,
it's beautiful.
Yeah,
that's great.
You get the right spot,
man,
but it's also,
I feel like it needs to be that close to
Los Angeles.
Yeah,
like you get a little bit of trickle.
I can sit down there 75 miles from my
house to your studio here in my office,
in Alta Dena for a skeptic magazine.
That's 105 miles.
So it's doable.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's.
I think that as human beings when
they're living in these gigantic
communities,
whether it's Los Angeles or New York or
something like that,
there's just a certain amount of people
become less valuable.
You know,
there's just too many of them and you,
you'll lose that sort of appreciation
for people and there's like a tension
around like you,
you don't mind if a few people drop off.
It's no.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
There's a balance in size.
My wife's from Cologne,
Germany,
which is about a 1 million people and
that's,
that's about as big as you want to get.
It's a big enough city.
There's lots of action,
could do all sorts of things,
uh,
but it's not 6 million or 10 million,
which is just like La.
It's just too many of you ever seen that
study that they did where they set up a
camera on one end of the street and the
camera on the other end of the street
and they timed people walking through
and in those,
in the,
the,
the footage of those people walking
through,
they were able to determine by how fast
these people walked.
They got an average of which was really
accurate of how many people lived in the
city.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The scale.
Yeah.
There's that book that physicist a West
Jeff G,
e o f f West I think is his name,
wrote that book and it.
And the bigger the city,
the more efficient and faster things
become including dialogue,
the way people communicate,
talk a little faster and faster.
And he had a formula showing how many
restaurants per one,
hundred thousand gas stations per
hundred thousand you'll get as you scale
up.
You don't need as many restaurants and
gas stations as populations increase
because there's more efficiency in the
flow of traffic and people throughout
the city,
whereas smaller towns are less efficient
that that was the theory,
but it's just fascinating that human
beings adjust because of all of these
other human beings around them.
They changed the way they walk,
they walk faster,
they talk faster.
So it's a right here scale scale the
universal laws of life and death in the
organism.
Cities and companies listening to it
right now actually coincidentally,
could winky dinky.
Yeah.
Um,
that's,
that's.
I mean,
you feel it.
You know,
when I lived in boulder for a shorter
amount of time,
one of the things,
you know,
Boulder's small as well,
I think it's 100,000 people.
When I came back here,
the first thing I realized is how fast
everyone's driving,
right?
Everyone's just cutting everybody off
and zooming ahead and,
and,
and people are really in a rush
everywhere they go.
And that has to be in some way,
shape or form.
It has to be influenced by all the other
people around them and their energy.
Right.
What is that?
What do you think that is though?
Well,
first of all,
it's all unconscious.
I think it's just mostly the kind of
overall pace you get that pushes
everybody along.
We're slows them down.
I just started this book called a rule
makers and rule breakers.
It's a by a woman who is a cultural
psychologist.
Sorry,
I forget her name,
the rule makers rule breakers.
So he talks about tight cultures versus
losing as fast as a fucking Michele
gelfand yet.
So she talks about tight versus loose
culture.
So like again,
my wife from Germany,
it's a tighter culture that the norm
that people are more likely to obey
norms and rules and there's a little
more uncomfortableness and violating
them.
California were a little loosey Goosey
about rules and,
and so my wife's,
I was giving me a hard time about,
you know,
my idea of traffic laws is I'll just do
whatever,
you know,
I feel like pretty much if,
as long as it's safe and I kind of know,
uh,
you know,
I'm driving up the one on one.
If I stay at a 79 or below,
I'm fine.
And she's like,
but the 65,
it's like,
yeah,
so what?
I mean,
I know where the cops park.
I know everybody else is going on in the
left,
turn into our street is a left Arrow.
So of course my wife,
she's just like,
well we got to wait.
It's like,
but it's midnight.
I'm just going to go.
You can't go.
It's like,
yeah,
this California,
I'm going
nowhere.
So that's a tight culture versus loose
culture.
So I guess she's going to talk about how
norms that affect laws and how then
people change their behavior.
You're not even aware that you're doing
this,
you're just kind of unconsciously
absorbing the cultures.
But what do you think?
But there's a difference between west
coast tight culture like la or large
groups rather an east coast large
groups.
Do you think that's influenced by
whether it's one of the things that I've
been thinking about a lot,
the,
the aggression of east coasters is very
different than the aggression of West
coasters and I always wonder,
it's like how much of that is because
they have to deal with shit whether for
five months out of the year it could be
that,
I don't know.
I'm a and the influence of immigrants as
well,
like because,
uh,
like my,
my parents,
my grandparents were immigrants.
They all came over from England and
Ireland and Italy and they were all
savages.
They were all people that were willing
to get on a boat and cross the ocean.
Right.
You know,
those are aggressive people.
They're like,
I'm getting Outta here.
Fuck you.
And then the landlord Alzheimer's,
you're higher risk takers.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So it's not a random population that
came to America,
nor with Australia,
you know,
you send all these converts on fixed.
They're not going to be a typical gene
pool there.
So meanwhile,
how good did that work out?
Those are the nicest people ever.
Well,
same thing,
you know,
Germans after World War One and World
War Two,
oh,
these are bellicose people,
but there are national character now.
They're the nicest people in the world.
They don't want to fight anybody.
Yeah.
That generation,
right?
More than that.
I mean they have massive war guilt and
guilt.
Uh,
yeah.
I mean they are all raised in taking
tons of classes in school about what
happened,
why we're never going to do this again.
Here's what we did at the Jew,
you know,
they're still paying Israel reparations
for that.
There are these little stumbling stones
that are the sort of brass square cubes
all over Germany of the name and year
that that person was murdered.
These are all Jews in front of the house
where they used to live there all over
the place.
Yeah.
I have a picture of him and the moral
arc here,
I'll show you.
It's,
it's really dramatic.
It's.
And when you literally stumbled across
them,
I mean,
they're just there in the street.
Uh,
you might,
if you google stumbling stones,
you can see that they're better in four
color.
Another interesting thing about Germany
is they won't let scientology and
sensitive about cults and cult behavior.
That's right.
Well,
there's another reason for that and that
is in the picture.
Now I'm in Germany.
Most people don't know this.
There's a religious studios.
Jamie's religion.
Yeah.
There they go.
Oh,
so that's what they.
So they're actually above ground.
So you're just walking along and you
look down and some of them,
those are not the.
They're not like that,
right?
They're not like little bricks on the
ground and they're like that.
You just said there in the ground and
the ground persons and they're in front
of the house where they used to live the
date that they were departed in the date
that they were murdered and where they
were murdered.
Auschwitz or a tribe triplink or dominic
and so on.
Yeah,
there you go.
So that's pretty moving.
It's and it's,
it's kind of a reminder,
this is what we did and we were not
going to do this again.
Remember?
So that's changing norms.
How does this happen?
Really?
It's that you can do it through the law
from the top down,
but really it's more a culture from the
bottom up.
You were saying that there's another
reason besides that,
besides the Holocaust,
that they're sensitive to scientology.
Oh yeah.
Because in Germany they have a religious
withholding tax.
So when you get your first job,
they do a withholding for your religion
and they give a percentage of your
paycheck to your religion,
the religion you were born into
baptized,
whatever.
It's mostly Catholic and Protestant,
but others want to get in on that
because that's cumulative.
You know,
you can make some money doing this as a
religion.
The humanists of Germany get a little
piece of this action.
It's considered a religion.
So scientology when they saw that,
they went,
oh,
okay,
free government money,
tax money,
and uh,
the Germans got,
no,
you're not a real religion.
You're not getting in on this.
And uh,
yeah.
So again,
when,
when my wife came here,
before she came here,
she quit church and you literally have
to go down to the courthouse,
fill out a form and say,
I am leaving the church.
Please don't take my money anymore out
of my paycheck.
So you have to opt out.
You will be giving money to your
religion unless you fill out the form
and opt out.
Wow.
And uh,
and,
and in this case it was kind of a funny
story.
They go,
okay,
so just to make sure you know,
now if you sign this,
you can't get married in the Catholic
church,
can't get buried in the Catholic church.
You can't go to the ceremonies and so
on,
you're done.
And she goes,
Yep,
that's the way I want it.
And she went down there with her four
horsemen,
tee-shirts,
said Dawkins,
Dennis Harrison,
hitchins.
And they're like,
who's this?
Anyway?
So they set up,
but now the moment you signed it starts
effective today.
But there's a three month lag for us to
not take the money out of your paycheck.
My wife is like,
yeah,
like,
wait a minute.
It went up in a business.
When it contract ends at ANZ for both
parties.
They go like,
no,
they just get to steal money for three
months,
three more months.
Yeah.
What a weird thing
that you have to opt out like that,
that it has to be so definitive that you
have to sign papers and go someplace.
What does fucking shady law it is?
It's no good.
I know that's gotta change.
So a lot of us are trying to talk people
into opting out quit church.
Well,
it is amazing that in this country I
would like to know what the number is if
the churches in this country had to pay
taxes didn't mean clearly,
especially when you look at the
televangelist that are driving rolls
royces and flying around in private
jets.
I mean there's profit is extreme amount
of profit and it's discretionary income.
They can do whatever they want with it
and you're,
you're dealing with massive,
massive sums of money and they don't
contribute.
So these people are clearly personally
benefiting from the contributions of
these people.
And then they don't pay taxes on it.
And in the case of like ministers who
live in a church owned home,
they don't have to pay property tax.
Uh,
there's a lot of hidden benefits there.
It's dirty,
it is dirty.
It's amazing that it's still here.
I mean,
especially when you deal with something
like scientology will,
you know,
the guy who wrote it like it's,
this is not some ancient texts that were
handed down from,
you know,
the guy and the guy was a terrible
writer.
I mean,
he was a terrible science fiction
author.
He just wrote every fucking thing he
wrote was a first draft,
just boom gone.
I mean,
it's just the most nonsensical nonsense
writing and yet they don't have to pay
taxes because it's considered a
legitimate religion.
Hurl is Harlan Ellison,
the great science fiction writer this
year,
uh,
told me the story of what the famous
story where l Ron Hubbard allegedly
said,
I'm going to go start a religion.
He said it was,
it's real.
It's a true story.
They were but,
but it was just a bunch of science
fiction writers sitting around like this
chatting and complaining about how
poorly paid they are.
They have to crank out by the word,
you know,
Kenny at word kind of thing.
And somebody said,
you know,
we should just start a religion and make
shit up like that.
And I'll,
Ron Hubbard says,
yeah,
you know,
that's a good idea,
I think.
I think I might do that.
And then he went out and wrote dianetics
and that became the founding document of
scientology.
Did you watch the,
um,
the HBO series on it?
The documentary rather?
Yeah,
going clear.
Unbelievable.
That's the best documentary on.
Of course,
I've seen AALIYAH's show.
She's got a big guts to go after.
I don't know if she's got good lawyers
are a and he has good lawyers or
whatever.
Maybe they've stopped suing people.
I don't know.
I think the climate has shifted and I
think people were more,
first of all,
for the longest time,
all we thought of when you thought about
scientology,
thought about positive thinking and John
Travolta,
Tom Cruise and they're all super
positive,
you know,
and they're getting things done and
there's auditing and they're really
taking care of their mind and thinking
clearly and eliminating all the negative
influences.
But then once there was a bunch of
factors I think.
But once the Internet opened up these
the doctrines and you've got a chance to
read it and people got a chance to mock
it and then South Park did that whole
series on it where they,
this is what they actually believe.
And you see like when south park did
that,
everybody was like,
Holy Shit,
wait a minute,
is that real?
And then people started googling it and
then looking into it and then it started
to unravel.
Slowly but surely people started leaving
the church,
Lawrence Wright wrote the book,
all these things are happening and now
Leah is coming in and Leah was,
you know,
I knew her but I mean I'm friends with
Kevin James from the king and Queen.
And so I,
I've known Leah for 20 plus years and
when I first met her she was just like
this hard ass beautiful woman who's just
like driven and like,
like she's a scientologist,
like Oh,
let's get the fuck out of her way.
You know?
It was like that.
She's just like super active and just
getting things done and just being
productive.
I mean,
that's what you thought about when you
thought about scientology,
but now what you think about it is
nonsense.
It's just foolishness and,
and once going clear area and you've got
to see l Ron Hubbard and listened to him
talk and you see the captain's outfit he
had on with the medals that he gave
himself.
Like what?
Who would buy this test?
Cell Dumb.
It's just,
it's amazing that it's so effective and
so financially successful.
Uh,
yeah.
I think their membership roles are
pretty low,
but their property holdings I think are
pretty extensive.
Yeah.
I mean they're the second biggest real
estate owner in Los Angeles.
Is that right?
Yeah.
At least they were.
There were some Japanese folks that were
number one and then it was a number two
was scientology.
Maybe that's not true anymore.
Might be oil barons now.
Well,
back in the nineties when the Internet
first got cranked up,
we were doing articles on scientology is
when some of these ex members started
posting the secret doctrines,
the news story and the going clear at
level eight or whatever.
When you find out the the,
the,
the inside story,
and they got raided.
I mean the scientologists went to court
to court to judges and said,
this is copyrighted material and it's
like,
what,
wait your religion,
how can you copyright of religious?
Well,
and they somehow got around that.
I mean,
this would be like the Catholic church
not telling you about Jesus and the
resurrection until level eight after
you've paid $100,000 or something like
that.
It's just insane.
Well,
what's amazing is that the irs caved in.
When that happened,
I remember when that happened,
I thought,
oh my God,
I don't want to fuck with these guys.
I mean they'd beat the irs.
I'm a nobody.
How am I going to defend myself again?
But maybe they've stopped suing people.
Maybe they're not going after Leah.
Like la real estate here goes portfolio
properties reported at $400,
million dollars in Hollywood alone,
paid for in cash.
No less.
The Church of Scientology is undeniably
a formidable player in the real estate
game.
That's what you got.
They have some beautiful properties to.
Yeah.
It's just really amazing.
It's amazing.
So you know,
my,
my skyping friends like,
oh,
they're going to go out of anytime soon.
It's like,
I don't know.
I think they could have practically no
members instilled.
They have all this real estate.
Here's the thing,
even though it's nonsense,
just
so is most religion,
let's just be honest.
I mean if you want to talk about guys
coming back from the dead after being
burned for three days or Adam and eve
being the only two people and they have
kids and their kids just started having
sex with each other and that makes all
the people in the world or Moses parting
the Red Sea and Jesus walking on water.
I mean,
you're looking at horse shit everywhere.
It's just older horseshit.
It's,
you know,
whether or not it's based on some real
events or some real people.
Who knows?
But it's all nonsense.
Have you ever heard a giulia,
Sweeney's monologue letting go of God?
No.
Do you know Julia from Saturday night
live?
I know who she is.
I do not know her.
She just moved back to La.
So you should have her on the show.
She's terrific.
Love to,
so um,
she was born and raised Catholic love
being a Catholic,
the whole culture and you all.
That was great.
And then she started reading Dawkins and
me and Harris and so on and then kind of
let all that go and then she wrote a
monologue.
It's very moving.
So the model like opens,
she's in her house in Hollywood and the
Mormon boys come by and she invites them
in and they want to tell the story and
she's thinking this is like a Hollywood
pitch story.
You're going to pitch the story and I'll
get back to you later.
Tell you to like it.
No,
no.
They wanted it to actually press to see
if she could join right then and there,
you know,
they're on their two year mission that
they do,
you know,
a picture of these 2:18 year olds with
their white starch shirts and their
bicycles.
And so Julia starts pressing him a
little bit.
So what's the story here?
Well see this guy,
Joseph Smith,
he,
he found these gold plates in his
backyard and he translated to them from
ancient hieroglyphics into English.
And with these magic stones and they're
going on and then Jesus came to America
and there was the good Indians and the
Indians.
And Julie's like,
I just want to tell them,
okay,
don't start with this story.
This is a bad pitch story.
Even the scientologists no,
don't tell them about new until way down
the line.
But then she says,
reflecting on it,
you know,
if,
if I told somebody my Catholic story who
never heard of it,
it would sound just as wacky because
it's virgin and the resurrection will
let all of its wacky.
One hundred percent.
I mean,
it's like we were talking about earlier.
When you die,
what's going to happen is you don't
know.
You don't know.
And the reality is,
look,
maybe there is an afterlife.
Maybe when we stopped living,
something happens and our essential
energy goes into another dimension.
It's possible,
but you don't know.
Look,
being alive is so titanic,
Lee Bizarre.
Just being a human being,
looking through eyeballs at each other
across from this wooden table that was
cut down from living organisms that
turned into hearts or surfaces,
sand them and saw him.
And then he put it in a building and
it's got electricity's rolling through
the walls and if you stuck a fork in
there,
you die.
All of it is the fact that we're on a
planet.
I mean the fact that the universe is,
at least as far as we can tell,
infinite,
all that stuff is crazy.
The idea that your essential energy
doesn't transfer into some other state.
Why not?
The whole thing is crazy,
but you don't know.
That's right.
No,
no.
You don't know to you.
Whenever you say something that you're
not sure of and you say,
this is what's going to happen,
but you don't really know.
You're a huckster.
That's right.
Yep.
Absolutely.
No one knows.
And that's the conclusion.
Heavens on earth.
I don't know.
And you don't either.
I saw a bumper sticker that said
militant agnostic.
I don't know.
And you don't either.
Uh,
so I mean we have to.
Okay.
So here's my bottom line on this yet.
I don't know.
You don't.
No one knows for sure.
I'm happy to wake up and some great
place and there's a lot of my friends
will be awesome unless.
Unless it.
God was mad that you didn't follow the
rules and all that.
That's right.
Christopher hitchens called the
Christian Heaven Celestial North Korea.
It's like,
here's this dictator.
Then knows everything you do and
controls everything forever.
Celestial North Korea,
but he doesn't tell you any more.
I told you already.
I told you 2000 years ago this dude
wrote it down.
Pay attention to that,
but then it's not even that,
right?
It's like one guy might've write it down
a long time ago,
but then a bunch of other dudes got
together and how to revise it.
They had like a new draft and the new
drug,
they get to decide.
People got to decide what goes in and
what doesn't go in and some of the
stories are based on accounts from
hundreds of years after Jesus's death.
Like the Bible is a Wiki.
It is like a wicked.
People contributed to over the years
until hitchens a at a great analogy with
a.
When he was dying,
he wrote a series of essays for Vanity
Fair,
his column a,
which you can get as a book now,
I think it's called mortality or
something like that.
Anyway,
I'm.
One of them was people think dying is
like you're at a party and someone taps
you on the shoulder and says,
you have to leave.
Now.
At worst the party is going to go on
without you.
It's like,
oh no.
He goes,
okay,
so let's play this out.
You're at the party and you get tapped
on the shoulder and said,
uh,
you can never leave the party.
You have to stay here forever with these
people.
Like when it,
Julie is funny,
lines is Mormon.
Boys were telling her like,
in heaven,
it's going to be great.
Um,
you,
you're made whole again,
like the blind shall see and the deaf
shall hear again in the crippled,
she'll be holding in.
And she said,
well,
um,
I had uterine cancer and I had my uterus
taken out.
Do I get my uterus back?
And they're like,
you can imagine these 18 year old,
like,
what's the uterus again?
And they're like,
yeah,
you get your uterus back.
She goes,
I don't want it back.
And then she said,
what if he had a nose job and you liked
it?
Do I have to have my old nose back in
heaven?
That's a good point.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
and then they said that,
and you get to spend the rest of
eternity with your family.
And she went,
oh no,
that would not be good in my case.
Maybe there'll be cured though.
They'll realize the errors of their
ways.
There'll be all enlightened.
Well,
here's the product.
So this is called the problem of
identity.
Who are you?
And you know,
the,
the theseus is shipped,
you know,
the Greek men Atar slayer,
theseus comes back and is a hero and
they,
and they preserve his ship and the
museum forever,
but the wood rots and they replaced the
ship.
And over the centuries there's no wood
left from the original,
but it's still cherished as if I call
this termers Mustang because my first
car was a 66 Ford Mustang classic.
And I had that for 19 years.
Those cars,
it's like it was a great car,
but I banged it up so much I replaced
this and that,
you know,
every pretty much.
By the time I sold it as a classic and
made a nice little chunk of change on
it,
there was very little of the original
left.
But it's the pattern,
not the material that counts.
So this whole debate about when you're
resurrected in heaven with Jesus,
what's up there?
Is that your physical body?
If,
because some Christian sects say,
yeah,
it's like,
okay,
how old are you when you're in heaven
30.
This is the year they came up with
because that's the year age Jesus was
when he was crucified.
Okay.
But if Joe Rogan,
I don't held 40 something.
Fifty 1:51.
Okay.
So if,
if you're a resurrected at 30 year old
Joe Rogan,
what happened to the last 21 years of
Joe Rogan's body memories?
I don't want to go back to that dude.
That dude was down.
You don't know.
You're happy where you are in your life
at this for sure.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well,
that means you're a well lived life,
so what's up there with Jesus a or
wouldn't mind having that body 30 year
old body problems?
I've been beating on it
21 years since then,
like when I was 13 when I got hardcore
into Jitsu,
so that's 20 years of getting choked.
Of course the Christian would say,
well God makes you whole again,
you'll have no injuries but that's not
really part of you.
Part of you is your injuries,
your muscles know
to say those,
but all those,
all the stuff that I did that hurt me.
I also learned from that's right.
Make you stronger but not just that,
like learned the story.
I think through incremental struggle
with whether it's rigorous exercise or
learning something or a.
I think everything that I do that's
difficult makes me just a little bit
more aware,
a little bit better at other things.
Just a little bit,
a little bit better to talk to a little
bit easier to deal with,
a little more friendly and all those
things.
I think I wouldn't give up for anything.
I think that's more important than
whatever injuries I've got with.
I think,
you know,
I,
I wonder how you're going to feel when
you're 80.
I wonder if you feel like that there's
got to be a point of diminishing returns
like that.
I'd rather be stupid and 40 than to be
enlightened and can't get out of bed
very well.
My older athletic friend is telling me
it's about mid eighties when things drop
off fairly quickly and they could stay
pretty fit into their seventies,
maybe still racing,
bike racing at 80,
but 85 or so things drop off pretty
quick.
That's where you've got to go to hormone
replacement or whatever.
Yeah.
Or the ice pledges or the.
Yeah,
the,
the young person's blood or something.
Okay.
So I deal with it,
you know,
there's no breakthrough miracles yet,
but again,
I'm not against any of these things
happening.
You know,
when,
when someone like Jeff Bezos puts
$100,000,000 into an aging company,
I hope he's successful.
Does he have $100,000,000 in an aging
company?
Uh,
he and Peter thiel and the Google guys
through Calico and a few others have
invested many hundreds of millions of
dollars into cup like Calico for
example.
These are companies that are trying to.
Their big goal is to defeat aging
through reengineering cells and um,
that,
that's the sort of philosophical goal
behind it is we have to defeat aging so
people can live for centuries or forever
to which I say,
let's not worry about living 500 years,
let's,
let's worry about prostate cancer and
breast cancer and Alzheimer's and
dementia.
And so I just,
the little incremental medical problem,
quality of life things were the things
that take people out young.
Yeah.
So that you can live a longer,
higher quality life.
But Imagine Michael Shermer at 300 years
old,
if not,
keep this body.
If you can keep the body that you have
now,
you're moving around,
great.
Everything's well.
You look really healthy.
How smart would you be?
How much?
How much more enlightened or wise?
Maybe
I'm not against that.
I'm happy to live as long as I possibly
can.
There are,
there are people that go,
well that's not right.
It's not natural.
It's like,
okay,
what's natural?
There's surveys on this people and
people's answer is whatever the current
average lifespan is.
So.
Well,
80 seems about right.
Okay.
Fast forward to your,
uh,
the day before your 80th birthday.
Tomorrow you're going to go.
You want another week?
Yeah,
I'll take another week.
Okay.
Then fast forward six days a,
would you like another month?
I'll take another month.
Thank you.
And,
and that would never end.
So of course if you're healthy and happy
and you don't want it off yourself or
whatever because you're super,
super depressed or something like that.
Yes.
You're just gonna want to keep going?
Nothing wrong with that.
If we can do that,
but what if you die and it's way better.
What if you die and you really do,
you leave your physical body.
There's no need for emotions and all the
entanglements of human existence and you
go to this beautiful place of bliss and
life and love and it's just pure love
without a body.
Yeah.
And embodied an unhindered.
I don't know what.
That'd be fun.
I don't know what's.
Is that what we're here for?
We're here for fun.
We're doing a shitty job.
The chatty going crazy right now.
Should be in a party van on the way to
Vegas.
I had a college professor when I was in
my Christian days who asked me when I
was pitching him the Christian story.
He says,
are there golf courses and tennis courts
in heaven because I like physical
challenges.
You want to get out there and push
myself like I don't know.
You know,
so I mean we'd haven't been no
challenges,
no working out,
no physical,
you know,
tensions and true,
right?
Yeah.
And maybe you don't need it,
so you'd have to remove that part of
humanity that we'd no longer
want challenges and to be pushed to
better ourselves.
Do they play chess in heaven
when
you get to win in heaven or is everybody
a winner?
Everybody gets a gold medal and a Nobel
prize and whatever.
That's.
That is a problem.
Are the things that we're attracted to,
things that we enjoy,
accomplishments and achievements and all
these things that they exist only inside
of the civilization inside of this,
this realm that we've created.
The significance of them is entirely
based on our own agreements that it's
important.
When you take the king right now,
it's important when the ball goes into
the net,
these we've agreed,
you know when someone shoots a three
pointer,
it's really not that big a deal.
You just throwing a ball into a hole.
Really significant happens,
but because we've attached all of this
meaning to that,
then it's something that we really want
to see and everybody score the goal went
in the Puck,
went in the net.
Yes.
It becomes this giant thing if they just
have no good answer for this.
When he said,
well,
what's heaven like?
Psychics will tell you it's a bliss and
lever would.
But what does that mean?
It sounds again,
back to hitch.
It sounds boring.
I have to stay at this party forever.
That sounds boring.
Did you ever see the guy who took a
photo of himself in heaven?
No.
You ever saw that
he used the Samsung Galaxy phone to take
a,
to take a picture of himself in heaven?
Are there what clouds are white is
smiling.
It is one of the funniest fucking photos
you're ever going to find on the
Internet just because of the context of
it and it's fun.
Yeah.
I believe he was an African gentleman
who was a.
either he's telling the truth or is
hilariously full of shit.
I mean,
imagine if he really did go to heaven
and took a picture and we're just
mocking them.
Really.
We should be going to him for advice.
That's right.
So what is it really found it.
You see the picture,
the mocking,
the memes of making fun of them
afterwards.
The actual picture.
I'm trying to find the original.
Just Google man takes.
I did.
That's what everyone wants to make fun
of.
The edit is so overwhelmingly mocking.
It's so good.
Oh,
that's got to be playing a large part.
Got It.
I think this is.
Everyone's saying this same this,
but no,
it was all white.
It wasn't like that.
It wasn't that.
It was just like that picture of him
holding his hand up like that,
but it was just the background wasn't
rainbows and shit like that.
You could find it,
man.
I have faith in you.
I found it the other day.
Um,
it's,
you know,
it's just hilarious that someone would
be so confident to put that picture
online knowing full well that the world
is going to see that picture and start
rubbing.
The Guy who sold his soul on Ebay.
I forget,
I forget what he got for it,
but a lot of religious people were
offended by this.
You can't tell your soul why not.
You sold your soul to your religion.
Did he get a good price?
I don't know.
I think it was a theater bucks or
something like that,
but he wanted to go to dinner with that.
Yeah,
that's right.
But my concern about all of this,
obsession with the afterlife,
that's not it.
This is from his page.
It says,
woke up this morning and saw this.
Had to take a picture.
Oh,
okay.
We'll start with devin.
That's not the actual photo.
That photo of him and having his.
What's hilarious is that picture with
him that far left,
far left.
That's it.
That's the photo.
That is him.
That is the photo.
Went to heaven and that's it.
That's the exact photo he took.
I don't know who took the puddle.
He's like,
Hey,
angel,
do me a solid.
Yes,
not a selfie.
So his one hand is down so he's not.
He's not taking it with that hand.
The other hand is up,
lets him in heaven.
Love it.
The Internet is so good for mocking
things though.
It's so good.
It's one of the best things ever in
terms of like there's so many people
that are paying attention and so many
people that are funny that aren't
comedians per se.
They just might work in an office
somewhere and they've got a little bit
of free time and they'll make a
hilarious meme about something and then
everybody runs with it and things just
get mocked mercilessly.
Remember the the video of the guy,
he was having an interview and his kids
started walking in behind him and he's
trying to talk about foreign relations
in Poland or something and the little
kid is back here and then somebody.
The life rushes in and so anyway,
there's a bunch of funny spoof videos on
that where it says some woman is sitting
there talking about nuclear strategy or
whatever,
and then the kid comes in,
she's ironing the shirt and then she
diffuses a bomb and then she cleans up
the socks or whatever.
It's really funny.
Yeah,
there's we,
we were always.
All of our information was distributed
to us through these very controlled
networks,
whether it's CBS or NBC or ABC and
everything was very cut and dry and very
professional in the way people talk.
The way information was presented,
but now it's just,
it's open and loose.
Like as soon as I find out about some,
something happened in the world,
I google it.
I go,
what is it?
What happened?
I Google it and then I'll go to twitter
and then when I go to twitter it's all
pictures and memes and it's the dude
with the question marks.
You know that guys like,
you know,
there's so many memes that people will
throw up when anything crazy happens in
the world.
It becomes so interesting to hear the
news and hear commentary on the news
from this just gigantic,
massive humans and it's what's most
funny or most interesting or most
succinct or poignant that rises to the
top.
Yep.
Yeah.
There's endless content to entertain a.
also just a high quality content.
I mean,
I'm a content producer,
I write and so on and but I am a huge
consumer.
I go,
most of the people I follow on twitter,
post articles,
most of them I want to read.
So in the course of a couple of hours,
my little window popups,
you know,
just spread across the top of the
screen.
I want to read all of these articles and
I plow through as many as I can.
They're pretty much like the Atlantic or
vanity time,
whatever.
They're pretty high quality,
well written articles.
The problem is as a content producer
myself,
is that the half life of these articles
is so short.
You know,
like when I post one of my scientific
American columns,
I put a lot of work into it and then,
you know,
like a couple of hours later,
maybe days later gone.
No one's talking about like,
well I put a lot of work into that,
but it takes me out of the equation.
Like the New York Times did that huge
New York Times Sunday magazine article
on trump's business going all the way
back to the seventies,
right?
They,
they spent like a year working on this,
like 10 journalists.
This would have been a pulitzer prize
winning piece.
This would have done in anybody else put
trump.
Right.
I mean they had his own business
contracts and lawsuits and you know,
all the shady stuff going on and this
got huge media attention for about a day
and a half and by Sunday morning,
by Tuesday,
no one's talking about this anymore.
It's like these guys spent a year
working on this.
I mean,
what did it take to get that lawsuit
paperwork from the Court House and they
had hundreds of things like that and
it's gone like,
whoa.
Well and trump in particular,
there's so many scandals that I think
we've all become numb.
Yeah,
there is that too.
Yeah.
There's so many that you just.
You get numb to it and it doesn't.
It doesn't affect you.
You just go like,
Huh,
he paid off at woman,
whatever.
Yeah.
Those are the tiny ones.
The big ones are the lawsuits,
the businesses,
you know,
the construction businesses where he
didn't pay small companies.
You didn't pay him like a tsunami.
Then these companies went under like
there's a lot of those.
There's a lot of the unethical business
practices.
That's all in that article.
Again,
anybody else would be done in by
something like that.
Any politician except him.
It's just amazing.
Well,
it's also what he represents to those
people.
It doesn't necessarily have to be what
he really is.
It's what he represents.
What he represents is like the American
flag and eagles and so like they have
this like really juvenile sense some
folks do.
Of what he is and what he represents
this,
despite all the evidence to the
contrary,
they have him in this category that he's
going to drain the swamp and these
liberals are just going to cry and he's
going to make America better.
Right,
and that's just,
that's.
That's the side that they're on.
They're on the make America better.
Do you think it's also people don't have
the time to really look into this stuff.
Who could fact check these things?
It's not just that.
It's like if you work eight hours a day
and you have children and hobbies and
how much time are you really paying
attention to trump's ethics,
you really,
really looking into it.
I really considering it before you vote,
are you really taking into consideration
what kind of a person he is and what
ripple effect it would have with any of
his policies take place?
I think you're right.
People vote by their team.
This is my team.
I'm sticking to it.
Okay,
so he won the primary.
All right.
That's.
That's our guy.
We're sticking with them no matter what.
I think there's a huge element of that.
For sure,
yeah.
There's also people love to argue too
and as soon
as they find someone as opposed to
something that they believe in,
they stick to their guns and they just
hold strong.
Despite all that mean,
it would take so much for people to turn
on trump.
The real hardcore trump believers would
take so much for them to decide enough
is enough.
That'll be interesting to see if members
of his own party do something in 2020,
probably not.
Doesn't it seem like with Fox that Fox
is slowly starting to shift their,
their coverage a little bit,
criticizing him a little bit.
They're pushing back a little bit.
Shepard Smith is pretty good on that.
He's always been that way.
He,
yeah,
he's always been great at that entity
will probably be last to go.
He's never going.
Never gone.
He's never gone.
They have the same fucking lawyer.
That's right.
The fact that that didn't say Canada.
Right.
You know that he had Michael Cohen was
his lawyer like,
oh,
Yep.
Yeah.
The only thing we can have an immediate
is that there's lots of sources and you
just have to just cross check as many as
you can.
Don't take on any one channel.
Well,
I wish there was a really truly
objective service,
like it would be wonderful if there was
people that were dedicated to know
editorial slant whatsoever.
Just 100 percent fact.
This is how we know the facts
regardless.
Left,
right?
No ideological curve to it at all.
Wouldn't that be fair?
That there's got to be a market to that?
Of course they all say that that's what
they do now.
Politifact is pretty good.
They,
they're the fact checking organization
that they're not reporting news.
They're reporting on politics on the
facts said by politicians,
so that's useful and I think there's a
market competition amongst those people
to get more hits like we're fact
checking more than the other guys are
fact checking.
Although there is two different.
There was aim accuracy in media and then
there was another one,
I forget the name and one was left
leaning and one was right leaning.
It's like,
can I have one without a wing,
right wing or left wing?
Yeah,
it seems like that.
I mean,
I'm reading Jonathan hates book,
the two books that I've been reading
recently.
One of them we discussed on the podcast
we did on Monday,
but the other one is the coddling of the
American mind.
That's good book.
And I'm into that now and it's,
it's fantastic.
And he goes,
he covers this quite a bit.
Yeah.
A,
you know,
Jonathan is onto something good there
with the Heterodox Academy,
which I'm a member.
I'm a professor at Chapman University
and so I was the first member there and
our university is pretty centrist.
Uh,
we don't get a lot of these protests and
microaggressions and safe space stuff.
It's,
it's pretty quiet.
And Jonathan's point is that it's more
of a sort of east coast,
west coast public university thing or
maybe Harvard,
that kind of thing.
Middle of the country,
you don't see as much of that.
Um,
but the,
you know,
the polarization thing has gotten worse.
You can see the polls since like 1990 to
2018 of,
you know,
you ask people how,
how evil are the Democrats or
Republicans and you know,
used to be tiny little differences
and then they,
you know,
they diverge like that now where the
other side is not just wrong,
but they're immoral.
They are people I do think talk radio
and television feeds into that or now
social media and in the bubble there.
So,
but on the other hand,
the,
and the heterodox academy as 2000
members now,
professors that said,
Yep,
I'm going to stand up against this
censorship on college campuses.
You,
you were talking to Jonathan about
people go and you had peed on and I've
known pete for many years before the
hoax papers and I think they've had it
in for him for a long before the hoax
paper.
But let's explain that to people.
So this can be standalone.
People goes in a James Lindsey and what
is the Long Island pluck rose.
And she wasn't on the podcast.
I didn't get to meet her,
but they,
um,
she's in England,
I believe they published a bunch of
preposterous papers,
like really ridiculous,
like on a,
you know,
a homeowner,
what is it?
The dog park one dog rape culture and
Park and the reach translation of a
chapter from mine comp,
replacing fem males with Jews,
eliminate the males that kind of.
So they did one before.
They actually,
Pete and James Lindsey did one two years
ago on the conceptual penis.
It was called and that the penis is a
concept.
It's not a,
it's not a real thing,
you know,
it's just,
it's a hilarious paper.
And the same month that came out,
it was published in a kind of a third
tier feminist studies journals.
So they get criticized like,
eh,
that's not one of the big ones.
So you didn't really post anything but
at the same week or that came out,
there was another paper published on
feminist glaciology and I thought,
oh,
someone beat pete to the hoax.
Oh my God,
this is totally.
And I read it.
I thought this is what's hot or bulleted
glaciology know study of glaciers.
Oh God,
yeah.
And that glaciers are very hard.
And,
and,
uh,
racked and you know,
it's all masculine and yeah.
Anyway,
so I called the university that was
affiliated with the lead author and I
said this is a hoax,
right?
Come on,
just before I say anything,
I don't want to be embarrassed.
This is a hoax,
right?
No,
no.
This is real.
It's like I can't tell the difference
between the conceptual penis paper,
which I know is a hoax because Pete
wrote it and the feminist glaciology
paper.
That's the problem.
Well,
let's explain what's happening to pete
now because pete was brought before a
Portland State University.
They,
there would be charged with,
uh,
with uh,
with faking data,
fraudulent data,
fraudulent research,
faking data that he didn't go through
the Institutional Research Board which
approves experiments that professors
want to run.
Like for example,
you could not do milgram's shock
experiments where you hook people up and
tell them that you're going to give
electric shocks to somebody.
They wouldn't approve that or,
or filled Zimbardo's fake jail who were
randomly assign students to be prisoners
and guards and they end up beating each
other up.
They would never approve that.
Okay.
So since those sort of guerrilla theater
experiments of the sixties,
the universities have tightened up,
the kind of research are allowed to do
even like the kinds of questions you
would ask in a survey.
They have to approve all of that.
So of course Peter and James and Helen
didn't do that because first of all,
you know,
James was the primary director of this
thing.
He's not affiliated with the university.
He doesn't have to answer to anybody.
Pete was affiliated with it,
so they're getting them on that,
um,
and that he didn't go through the IRB
and get approval.
Of course,
if you're going to tell people,
if you're going to fake something,
you can't tell them ahead of time that
we're gonna fake,
of course,
because it's going to get out.
And then the Gig is up.
The analogy I made a the other day was
in 1971,
a stanford psychologist named David
Rosen,
who's a clinical psychologist,
sent a bunch of his graduate students
into mental hospitals all over the
country and said,
just tell him you're feeling kind of
blue and that you're kind of hear this
inner voice and that,
uh,
it's just,
you just kind of don't feel right and
you need some help.
So they did.
They all get themselves checked in and
then from there on out they acted
perfectly normal and then the goal was,
let's see how long it takes you to get
out.
And so it was a study and how mental
hospitals treat people who are
completely sane.
So the title of his famous paper is
called being sane in insane places.
So first of all,
the Grad students report it's incredibly
boring.
So one of them would sit there and write
essays and take notes.
And,
and so in the psychiatrist evaluation of
this patient,
patient is,
you know,
patient exhibits,
excessive writing behavior.
This is clearly an example of his
erupting had bitten libidinal impulses
from his childhood and Blah,
blah,
blah.
Another one was a painter,
so she's doing paintings,
but landscapes and so on.
Oh,
patient.
You can see in the paintings the
erupting emotions and they conflicts in
her personality.
They're just acting normal.
Right?
So the point of this hoax was that
there's something wrong with our mental
institutions that they can't tell the
difference between a sane and insane
person.
What are they doing?
So of course the,
the,
the industry got pretty upset about
being hoaxed.
So Rosanna and came back and said,
okay,
in the next year I'm going to send in
some more.
Let's see if you can find him.
And he didn't send anybody.
Oh Wow.
So they're like,
okay,
we think this guy's fake again.
They couldn't tell the difference in
their own patients and no one was even
faking.
So in a way,
this is kind of what Pete and James and
Helen did is like,
if they're sending these papers out,
if you can't tell,
then what are you doing in this field?
Well,
people are,
for whatever reason,
people are.
Some people I should say are drawn to
these nonsense ideas.
And one of the papers,
the dog park paper got it,
got lauded for its excellent
scholarship,
got praised.
It's one of the weirder ones that they
hoaxed I mean because it's so obviously
preposterous when you're reading it,
you're like,
I think it was the fat bodybuilding one.
They get another one.
I think I won an award for the best
paper we've ever had.
Oh
really?
Peter and James and Helen,
they,
they are like professional scholars in
the grievance studies because it's.
If you read those things,
it's hard to write like that.
I mean it takes,
it took them a lot of practice to get
the jargon in the style then.
Well,
what do you think is the.
What are the options for someone like
Pete?
Because if he does get fired from the
university,
what,
what could he possibly do?
I mean,
what Jordan has done is pretty
extraordinary.
He's essentially left teaching at
because of the controversies that he
went through,
he became famous.
He became famous for doing podcasts and
writing things and then his youtube
videos are,
they're so insightful and,
and wonderful that people just got drawn
to him.
And then they go to see him speak live.
They've made him into a monster,
but bite censoring him by attacking him.
They've essentially turned him into a
global international star.
That's right.
This is one of the best arguments
against censorship is going to have the
opposite effect.
You wanted to.
If someone is a.
The quality of Jordan.
Peter says,
it's pretty rare.
It's pretty rare.
I've talked to pete about this as well
as Bret Weinstein because he had
suffered the same thing at evergreen and
he's out,
at least he and his wife Heather got a
payout so they have a little cushion.
But this model,
like say I'm on Patrion or Dave Rubin,
especially Jordan Peterson,
very rare.
It's very rare to be able to make a
living as a public intellectual on your
own.
Most public intellectuals that are not
in academia there with a think tank.
Uh,
you know,
the Cato Institute or reason magazine or
any of these,
there's a left wing right wing.
They're all over the board.
Uh,
you know,
it's possible they could get jobs there.
We actually have a paycheck and those
groups are usually funded by wealthy
supporters that we like the cause and
here's a pile of money,
not through Patrion.
Uh,
it's possible that pete say bread could
do this,
but it's a tough road to hoe.
I mean,
Jordan is very rare.
I've watched this through my whole life
and you know,
this idea of making $10,000 talk
$50,000,
$100,000 a talk,
almost nobody gets that kind of money.
You know,
maybe Neil degrasse Tyson,
Richard Dawkins,
maybe Carl Sagan back in the day,
whatever the equivalent of that would
have been in the eighties.
But that's pretty much it.
Uh,
you know,
and there's thousands of scientists that
would love to do that.
Like,
yeah,
I want to go that.
Well,
they're not entertaining.
The thing about Jordan is he's very
engaging,
like he's in his words are,
it's not just their wise,
it's not just,
he's a very articulate.
There's something engaging about the
style in which he presents these things.
It's very captivating because very
charismatic.
I agree.
People discount that.
Or I know a lot of scientists who were
kind of jealous of Neil degrasse Tyson
or say Bill Nye.
It's like,
oh,
I could do that.
No,
I doubt that you can.
I mean,
Neil and bill are really entertaining.
They are funny.
They are engaging.
You can't take your eyes off.
Then they're so much fun to watch.
Well,
perfect example is people are not like
that.
Sean Carroll's brilliant.
He's really brilliant and I'm glad that
he's doing a podcast now,
but when you listen to him talk and you
listen to neil talk,
Neil just has this booming presence and
this sense of drama and energy and
entertainment.
He knows how to be.
He,
he,
he knows how to deliver it in a way that
just catches you.
It's fun to listen to.
And I did a public event in Australia
and in Melbourne or Sydney and I,
unfortunately I went before him and
maybe that's actually good a.
and I'm a pretty good public speaker.
I have a sense of,
you know,
my value as a public speaker.
I'm pretty good.
But uh,
and I never seen him speak and I,
and I did my talk,
like my pretty much like my ted talk you
can watch online.
It's pretty entertaining.
Okay.
So I get up and I'm done.
I get a nice applause.
I'm feeling pretty good and then neil
gets up and he starts.
I'm like,
Oh crap,
this guy is fucking good and you don't
want to follow that.
I know.
I'm so glad I already went and got so
much energy.
Uh,
and,
and yeah,
but he also has that sort of charisma
connection with the audience.
A captures them and yeah,
I could tell afterwards,
you know,
wrongs of people around him and you
know,
it's there and not very many people had
that and I don't think it's something
you can just learn.
I think it's a temperament,
you know,
I mean you can hone it and refine it,
but he can't just sort of naturally be
funny and engaging.
I think it's personality that comes out.
I think you could certainly improve,
but I think you're right.
I think whatever personality you have,
like he has that kind of engaging,
fun personality and it's,
it translates very well to doing those
public speeches.
Since I was here a year ago,
I saw Jordan's event at a in thousand
oaks at the Kavli theater there in 2000
seats sold out standing room only.
And it was good.
He was like different than Neil of
course,
but just as engaging wasn't political.
A lot of people there I,
you know,
recognized me and I could see,
these aren't like right wing nuts,
these aren't young mailed,
angry males.
This isn't like this at all.
And his message was pretty
straightforward and get your life in
order,
you know,
this is the way life is.
It's hard.
And he kind of went through his thing
and it's like,
all right,
that makes sense.
And people loved it.
Very almost no politics in it.
Dave Rubin tells me he doesn't really
get political on stage,
so that's not the motive.
And uh,
I think,
you know,
life is hard enough for most people that
they,
they like back to the self help thing.
It's nice to be reminded,
here are a few simple things you could
do.
You get your life in order is like,
yeah,
well,
I kinda knew that I'm going to go back
out and do that again.
His principles are very effective to.
So they're very straightforward as you
said,
but what the guy like people goes,
you know,
to bring it back to that.
What,
what could he do if he does get fired,
it's going to be very difficult for him
to get a job at another university.
He's obviously got roots in Portland.
He lives there now.
It's the whole thing is he's pretty
liberal.
It's not like he's a closeted
conservative and thereafter him,
he's definitely more liberal than me and
I could tell even years ago that,
uh,
they're gonna,
they're gonna go after him.
I can tell mainly because he's so.
He puts truth and free speech ahead of
political positions.
He'll,
he might say,
I'm a liberal and these are my political
positions,
but more important to me is the truth.
Yes.
Okay.
Well that's not as Jonathan make point
points out in his book.
Universities are now at this divide
between are we here for social justice
or are we here for truth and they're
having to make a decision and too many
of them are going for it.
We're here for social justice.
Well then just be honest about it
because that's not.
You can't bury it.
Well,
not just that.
I don't think that's an effective way to
pursue so social justice.
If you're ignoring the truth,
you undermine your message because then
it's not like it's hidden somewhere.
It's not like people can't read into it
and see exactly what you've said and how
you've supported certain causes and
denied the reality of others,
but the.
The,
the Google memo thing.
Yeah.
The Google memo thing was a gigantic
disaster.
Yeah,
because ideologically people jumped on a
side and argued and and I heard the CEO
of Youtube talk about how damaging it
was to women.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Like what are you saying?
Like what?
What did he say?
He's just talking about preferences that
are described by tests.
This is,
this has all been peer reviewed,
studied papers on the differences
between the preferences of males versus
females.
It's not,
it's not like a value assessment at all
and in fact,
not only that he put into his paper a
page and a half of recommendations of
how to get certain women interested in
tech and perhaps you could recruit
certain way and make it more palatable
or exciting to them and that's not a
sexist screened at all.
No,
no,
no.
There's online.
There's a really good debate with Steve.
Steven pinker in,
in a,
in a feminist scholar at Harvard and
Steve has all his slides up there and he
just goes all through all the different
things that are in that Google memo.
This is before the Google memo,
May,
maybe James more gut,
some of that from pinker's lecture,
but it's,
it's,
it's pretty solid stuff.
There was nothing in inflammatory about
the debate.
This is kind of normal scientific
debate,
you know,
here's a study that shows this well,
but there's this other study and then
they go at it.
Okay.
And to story,
we're not saying women are better,
men are better.
That doesn't happen.
Unfortunately.
The here,
if I was [inaudible] boss,
here's what I would do because a lot of
us have written letters in support of
Pete and you can kind of see what's
about to happen.
Let's just drop this whole thing.
Let him keep his job,
keep our mouths shut because this is
going to backfire on us.
Big Time lag did with evergreens.
Yeah.
Or with the Google memo.
So that's what I would do.
Backfire on the Google memo.
I mean we've realized that they've got a
preposterous ideology over there.
Now we know that maybe their stock price
hasn't gone down.
Actually it affected them very much and,
and,
and many more people support it.
Many more people who.
It's one of those things where you hear
one version of it and that version
sticks,
you know,
it's like,
this is the version is he's a sexist,
you know,
the sex is Google memo and then that's
all I need.
The Google memo is very sexist,
very anti female.
And being.
There's many,
many people who support the idea that
something that was sexist was removed
from Google.
They've made it a safer environment for
women.
Right?
Yep.
But did they idle,
you know,
I don't know what this doesn't seem like
they did.
It seems like they made it an
environment where you have to be careful
about facts.
Right?
Because again,
it's not a value assessment of women.
If women choose to go into the medical
fields,
more women are physicians,
more women.
There's many fields that like
disproportionately attract women.
That's not a negative value assessment.
That's just people are different,
you know,
I don't,
I don't want to do with certain people
do because I'm different than them.
I don't.
I'm not attracted to those fields.
Right.
It's fascinating to find out why people
are attracted and when you see that
there's actual.
There's just actual statistics in terms
of what fields men are more attracted to
or what fields women are more attracted
to.
Now on the other hand,
if there's a reason why women aren't
attracted those fields because they get
harassed when they go into them,
well that should be demonstrated and
that's an APP,
obviously a bad thing and that should be
addressed.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Totally.
That's not what he's talking about.
And James Demore is like a very kind,
soft spoken.
He's great.
He's a great guy.
He's very introverted.
He's a kind guy and he's on the spectrum
somewhere.
There's no way you'd look at James
Amaury got fares.
The patriarchy.
Yeah.
He's a nice guy and they said to him,
if you have any input on these things
and feel like you can help,
please contribute.
And he's like,
okay.
So he's.
That's what he is.
He's a,
he's a fucking software engineer.
He sat down and looked at all the data
and compiled it and he's saying,
well actually it seems like this is the
reason why women are more attracted to
other jobs and this is the reason why
men are more attracted to these fields
and they're like,
sexist lead.
He's like,
no,
no.
These are the studies.
This is what you're asking me to do,
that the concern that if the science
doesn't come out a certain way,
then people won't be treated equally is
a bad idea because then you're going to
force the science to be distorted
if it doesn't match your political
ideology,
and that's so whether trans is natural
or whatever percentages or how old you
have to be before you get trans surgery
and the hormones or whatever that.
That's a raging debate right now,
but under,
under underlying that debate is like we
have to make it come out in a way that
trans people are treated equally.
It's like,
no,
no.
They should be treated equally anyway,
regardless of what the science says,
but,
um,
that,
that's,
that's a problem now.
Now the problem for people,
a peed and Brett like joining a think
tank is almost all these think tanks are
politically affiliated left or right.
You have to bet and therefore you have
to kind of tow the political line.
This is our ideology in this thing tank
and you're going to write white papers
and op eds and send them out with our
kind of slant,
the problem with that as well,
but what if I disagree with this and
this and this here?
Well then you can't work here.
Something like that.
So that's the problem with those.
Is that
the only option today when you see that,
I mean,
I know he's not Jordan and you know,
there's very few people like Jordan,
but Sam Harris is also able to do these
species very compelling as well.
He's doing a lot of public speeches and
doing these big,
big events.
There's more opportunity to do
alternative things now than they have
ever been before and I would hope that
that becomes available to look.
I hope Pete just keeps his job,
but if he can't keep his job at Portland
state,
I would hope that some other avenue,
some other,
some other path as possible.
Yep.
It might be.
You know,
you never know,
but you know,
you put a date on the calendar and you
tell the world,
did they come?
Do they pay 10 bucks a ticket,
50 bucks a ticket,
$100 a ticket.
Not many people can fill a 3000 seat
auditorium or a 500 seat auditorium in
do is do a lecture series on the
Grievance Studies and have the three of
them onstage talk about how silly these
things were.
Yeah.
If they could put that together as a
theatrical presentation,
it would really be funny because there's
some hot alaria subjects covered.
Oh,
they have to do is just read with
porcelain
[inaudible] and we're in here and we
were talking about these things.
We were crying laughing.
It was really,
really funny stuff.
That's actually probably the best path
for him.
Yeah.
Is to put together some sort of a public
show.
They should do a book and then have a
book to show.
Yeah.
And then maybe even a TV documentary
about it.
Well,
if they have somebody making a document,
that's a good start.
And when I was in College at Pepperdine,
g Gordon Liddy and Timothy leary did a
stage show.
Wow.
And they were.
And they were touring the country doing
this.
Yeah.
And it was at Ucla,
so I drove down and saw it and it was so
entertaining.
I mean,
g dot Gordon Liddy,
he's the man there with his three piece
suit and he's got his gun and Timothy
leary comes out in his boat shoes and
his flower shirt and,
but they had it kind of scripted,
but it was well scripted in a way that
seemed kind of spontaneous,
but it was really funny and educational
about how the government works and
freedom versus security and rights.
And uh,
I thought that was brilliant and I think
they did,
I don't know,
like a 50 city tour of that g Gordon
Liddy was on fear factor.
He was.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
Interesting.
Did he hold his hand above a flame?
No,
he didn't.
But we did hang him by his ankles and
slam them into a pool like over and over
and over again.
It was,
I forget what the stunt was,
but I was like,
Jesus,
this guy's old to be doing this.
But,
uh,
he did,
some physical challenges.
I remember thinking like this guy is
more fit and more active than most young
people,
and he was deep into his sixties at the
time when we had them on fear factor,
the only thing that screwed them up was
in the end,
the final stunt was a driving stunt and
it was at night and unfortunately his
eyes are not that good and he just
couldn't see well without glasses and so
as he was driving the car slammed into
something or something.
You know what it was?
What do you got them there now it's all
right,
but a chance to talk to him for a few
days hanging out with them.
Very interesting guy.
You have a strong mind.
Yep,
that's right.
He had a talk show back in the nineties.
I was on when my first book came out.
White people believe weird things and I
talked about conspiracies there and so
he asked me,
well,
tell me about conspiracies.
They.
Well,
you tell me about conspiracy.
You know more than I do.
He knows about real ones.
Real ones.
Yeah.
That is my number one beef with
conspiracy theories,
is that when you,
you know,
some of them that are so preposterous,
like whether it's flatter,
if or what were the really dumb ones,
there's a base on the opposite side of
the moon and Nasa knows about all the
aliens are living in New Mexico,
the lizard people.
The problem with those is they undermine
actual conspiracies when you,
when you hear about preposterous things
and they they get,
they get categorized as conspiracy
theories.
Then when someone says,
well,
there's a conspiracy about this.
Well,
it's already a tainted idea because the
word conspiracy is connected to
nonsense,
right?
Because there's so many nonsense
conspiracy theories.
It's hard to recognize,
oh,
something like Enron that really did
happen.
Like there,
there is the northwoods papers,
there's a bunch of like legitimate
conspiracies.
You're like,
wow,
you know,
you find out about the Gulf of Tonkin.
You're like,
well,
they really did that.
Yup,
that's right.
Yeah.
I'm writing a paper now and white people
believe conspiracies and so I go through
the whole list of all the psychological
things,
but I am with the whole second half is
because a lot of them are true and there
are reasons we should be suspicious that
just think of,
uh,
the wiki leaks or the Panama papers,
the Panama papers.
Here's all these billionaires opening
these shell corporations keeping their
mind.
They're not paying tech.
That's a conspiracy,
you know,
by definition to them are people meeting
in secret to conspire to benefit
themselves that harms the public good or
other people.
This happens a lot and the US government
in corporations,
there's a reason we should be
suspicious.
There is.
But what is it about people want to look
for
a conspiracy and everything,
even if it's,
you know,
they want to see,
they want to see contreras behind jets
as evidence of the government spraying
things in the sky to control our minds.
Right?
So the sort of Baloney detection tools
are not too finely tuned.
Uh,
the problem is,
is that we're a tendency is to look for
some global,
simple explanation for complex systems.
So while we all kind of recognize,
yes,
we know corporations cheat and stock
traders trade with insight information,
but that's kind of small and mundane.
It's not very interesting.
Global domination of the world know this
is,
Ooh,
who's doing that?
You know,
so then it becomes like a Dan Brown
novel.
It's more compelling as a narrative
story about how the world works.
It's super simple.
There's these 12 guys in London called
the Illuminati and they're calling the
shots and they're,
you know,
they're controlling Oldenburg,
the builder Burgers,
the Rockefellers,
the last child,
the Illuminati CFR new world order
towards Soros is doing it.
He's a part of it.
Totally.
It's what I hear.
He's number 13 in the Illuminati.
There's so many different competing
theories to so,
so,
so a couple of criteria.
The more people that have to be
involved,
the less likely it is to be true.
It was Gordon Liddy that told me this,
that,
you know,
it was,
it.
Three people can keep a secret if two of
them are dead now people can't keep
their mouth shut.
And also he would know because he worked
in government.
Most people are pretty incompetent.
So the idea that you can orchestrate a
thousand people to and each of them is
going to go out and do this one thing at
9:00 Tuesday and it's all gonna come
together just perfect because impossible
and he should know.
I mean they couldn't even break into the
Watergate hotel room to get these
papers.
What's also,
who is getting into government the first
place?
Are they the geniuses of the world,
the heads of their field?
Or are they people that just decided to
get into a job?
You know,
and this is,
this is a good percentage of the people
that are involved in government.
If those people know as well,
these unexceptional folks that are just
like uninspired.
And there were also,
they're like,
they,
that's the air quotes day that they
really have the kind of wherewithal to
control the whole world mind control.
That's my favorite mind control psyops.
I mean,
this idea that,
um,
you know,
operatives went into the World Trade
Center buildings,
both of them,
two of the most tightly controlled and
secure buildings in the world and under
the pretense of working on the
elevators,
managed to get into a breakthrough,
the drywall to get into the main beams,
to wrap them up in explosive devices.
This thermite stuff,
and this would,
you know,
we know how long it takes to demolish a,
like a stadium or a big building,
you know that they work,
they're there for weeks or months
preparing all the explosive devices.
Somehow they did this in the World Trade
Center building without anyone noticing.
Not to mention all the people that
worked on this,
they never told their spouses are
friends or buddies or what they were
doing or they didn't mention it to
anybody.
They don't want to go on CNN or 60
minutes ago I saw something and here's
what happened.
Nobody.
Well,
anytime you have a gigantic catastrophe
like that,
just a gigantic,
horrific event,
there's so many emotions.
There's so much chaos.
There's so much going on that you're
going to get a bunch of really wacky eye
witness accounts because people just
aren't good at remembering things when,
when they're under extreme duress and
mrs fact they hear things,
they remember explosions,
they see things that aren't necessarily
what was really in front of them and
that's just the human memory is one of
the most flawed ways of gathering
information,
right?
It's terrible.
We have terrible memories,
right?
And everything.
Once something happens,
then you back up and look for all the
sort of pregnant moments leading up to
it that otherwise would have been a
noticeable like,
uh,
at the JFK assassination.
There's a famous story about the
umbrella man.
Yeah.
Okay.
So there is,
it's a clear sunny day.
Why does he have an umbrella?
And for decades there you go online,
you can see these examples of how the
umbrella could have been turned into a
rifle.
And then he shot like that and,
and it.
Anyway,
somebody finally tracked this guy down
decades later and he said,
I was out there protesting Kennedy.
The umbrella was a protest.
And that stems back to Neville
Chamberlain coming back after meeting
with Hitler before Hitler annexed,
I think it was the sedate and land.
And he came back and said,
you know,
holding his umbrella here I had here,
Hitler sign this paper and promised he
wouldn't do anything more bad.
And so the umbrella became a symbol of
um,
you know,
sort of caving into evil people or you
know,
uh,
what's the word for it?
Uh,
you know,
appeasement.
How convoluted do you think people are
going to get that?
And I dunno,
he's out.
So this is what he said I had my
umbrella to because I didn't like what
Kennedy was dealing with,
Castro and the Cubans.
Okay.
So in other words,
the umbrella meant nothing in terms of
the assassination.
Right?
And this is true.
So like nine slash 11.
Oh,
there was this little puff of smoke or
somebody found this passport over here,
this little thing.
All those little things.
Really.
It's just randomness.
Well,
the other thing is the people that want
to think that the windows blowing out or
indicative of some sort of a controlled
demolition or the building's caving in
it,
the floor pancaking it pushes the air
out.
Yeah.
Well,
it's.
There's never been a controlled
demolition that went from the top down
either like the way they did it.
They all go from the bottom up,
right?
Yeah.
It's the one that looks crazy as a
building seven tower seven.
That one looks crazy.
It does,
but it burned for like eight hours or
something and yeah,
that one's just slightly fuzzier,
but explosive experts tell me that it's
fully explicable by burning all day.
Well also when you see the images of it
collapsing,
what you don't see is the interior
structure had collapsed previously and
there's video of that when you watched
the interior cave in and that as this
fire was burning because apparently
there was obviously,
I don't know what really what happened,
but there was diesel tanks apparently in
the basement and the diesel fuel at
burn,
incredibly hot in the whole inside of it
all.
The structure had been completely
weakened and then as it collapsed it
just all gave out.
It just happened to be a shit design.
If I was the guy who owned that
building,
I would sue everybody.
I mean he got his money back I guess
because there's some insurance money,
but that what a terrible design.
There was some issue with the legal
insurance payout to the owner of the
World Trade Center buildings.
Whether this was like one event or two
events are one building or two.
What was the difference was between like
8 billion,
$16,000,000,000 payout or something like
that.
How do they get people to get into that
new building?
I'd be like,
fuck you.
I'm not.
I'm not renting an office in this
building,
this building.
They blew it up in [inaudible] 93.
They blew it up again in 2001 get out of
here with this shit.
I'm not taking chances of this new ass
building.
What is it?
The freedom tower or something like
that.
It's just a big old bullseye.
Yup.
Yeah.
I haven't been in it yet.
I've been around it,
but it's not even that big.
Well,
it's.
I think it's just.
I think it's taller than the.
It's not.
It's not as big as the original towers.
Right?
I think it is as tall it isn't.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I thought it was shorter.
It's definitely not as big as the one in
Dubai.
The Dubai ones,
like a half a mile,
right?
Isn't something crazy like that.
I don't know how tall is the tallest
building?
It is.
I just went to their,
the one world trade center leasing page,
it says at 1,776 feet.
One World Trade Center is the tallest l,
e e d gold certified building in the
Western Hemisphere.
That's not good enough.
Whatever America,
we need to believe,
number one,
and we need to go straight to the moon.
In the solar system.
Yeah.
We need to take an elevator right to the
fucking moon.
Right.
Outside of space.
How is that possible?
Can they build a building that's so high
that it goes into space one?
Yeah.
I don't think so because structurally it
wouldn't hold,
went up,
so can shape of a pyramid.
Well,
it's like why are trees 100 feet tall?
Because the material would just
collapse.
I don't think he could have it strong.
It'd have to be so fat.
Oh,
that's right.
Japan was going to build that space
elevator.
Oh,
look at it.
You Got Jack with the popups.
Japan takes tiny first step towards
space.
Elevator.
Yeah.
You can fuck off.
I'm not getting nothing.
It would take a few years before I'm
willing to climate or that soccer.
But um,
so the other problem with conspiracies
just get back there for a moment is the
problem of anomalies.
What do you do with anomalies?
This is true in all science.
No theory explains every single thing
that's out there that we want to study.
There's always going to be some quirky
thing that the main theory here that
explains all these things here.
It doesn't account for that.
Okay.
What did we do with that?
Well,
my joke is you assign it to a Grad
student.
They let them figure it out.
But what outsiders mistake is that,
well my theory explains this,
a little anomaly,
so therefore it should replace this
theory and so people like Neil and Sean
Carroll,
Lawrence Krauss,
Michio Kaku has to web pages.
One is a link on his webpage.
If you have an alternative theory of
physics,
go to this page.
So they go there and it has your theory
has to explain all of these things over
here that are theory currently explains
and your whatever your said anomaly is.
And of course they can't.
So it's not that scientists are
dogmatically closed minded to the
anomalies.
It's that we can't explain everything
and you don't have to do anything with
that.
Just just leave it there.
Maybe eventually they'll pile up and
there'll be a new theory like with
Einstein's relativity.
Okay.
There was enough anomalies here like the
orbit of mercury and a few other things.
And so we have to modify Newtonian
physics a little bit.
Okay.
That happens.
But for the most part.
And so conspiracies are filled with
these things.
Like the moment something big happens,
you go back and okay,
but there was this weird thing here.
How he explained that,
I don't know,
we don't have to explain everything.
Do you know that there's a growing
movement that think that the space is
fake spaces fake?
No.
Is this different than the flat earth
rule?
Hashtag [inaudible] basis.
Fake Hashtag spaces.
Fave is people that are so fucking
stupid.
The flat earthers kicked him out.
Oh my God.
For real flat earthers kicked out the
space.
Fake people spaces fake is like God.
They are the most skeptical.
So what would be the upper atmosphere
would be the edge.
It's all bullshit.
It's all fake.
It's the end and it's tied in some weird
way to religion,
which is really interesting because even
the flat earth people,
there's a tremendous amount of them that
are extremely religious and they talk
about the firmament and the Bible book,
the Bible,
and that this is a.
This is what's really going on is that
they're trying to keep us from the
knowledge that God has created.
This place is a very special place and
so by pretending that it's round,
they somehow or another are controlling
us.
We're thinking that we're not
exceptional and we're not lucky.
Space is fake.
They're using a video from Ryan
Gosling's movie he just made about Neil
Armstrong.
First Man on the moon.
Just be like this.
Look,
look.
Here's proof.
It's a fake everything.
They are making a movie because
literally the way they made the movie is
that's evidence that it's fake.
That because he's wearing it.
I don't know if maybe this person
doesn't recognize that as being Ryan
gosling right there.
Scott got NASA suit on.
Maybe it's just a troll account.
This is how NASA fix everything.
This is the video I was talking about
guys.
Now you know it's all a big act tab.
Click on spaces fake though.
This is what I'm on.
I'm on the whole click on it because
there's a bunch of other mom on that
thread.
There's a tremendous amount of people
that literally believe that space is not
real.
Google a video of a buzz Aldrin and how
deals with the
no Mooney's that we never went to the
moon.
There's a video buzz Aldrin punching a
guy.
That guy,
I had dinner with that guy.
Did the guy who punched.
Yeah,
I was a firm believer that we never went
to the moon.
This is what happened.
I watched that.
A Fox documentary,
the moon conspiracy theory did we go and
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Because it was on television and I was.
And this was
96,
97.
I remember I went to work and I told
everybody,
you got to see this documentary.
It crazy.
We never went to the moon.
And uh,
I have watched that one and I watched
this guys.
What is his name?
Artsy fartsy liberal.
So I had dinner with them.
He absolutely believes that we never
went to the moon.
Not 100 percent believes it.
I don't know if he still believes it.
I think he's like a cab driver or
something.
Now he got,
he was involved in the news or local
television or something like that
backwards from then he released a
documentary called the funny,
a funny thing happened on the way to the
moon.
And in his documentary,
one of the things he did have his really
interesting footage of the lunar module
where it looks like they're faking a
shot of them being really far out,
but then when they remove this,
cover,
the covers from all the windows that
were inside the,
the um,
the lunar,
not the lunar module.
What is the one that the orbiter,
it really looks like they're in low
earth orbit and this is like the main
thing pointing to that,
like they couldn't get out of low earth
orbit.
Then there was also the fact that they
lost all of the telemetry data,
which was the binary ones and zeroes
that show the position of the lunar
module at every stage.
There was a bunch of different things.
The fact that no one wanted,
especially Neil Armstrong,
he became a recluse.
Never wanted to talk about it.
You go and watch the press conference,
the press conference.
They look very shady,
look like they're completely not like
that.
He talks to everybody.
He was a drunk for a long time though.
He was a.
He was very depressed and had when he
became an alcoholic after the moon
landing.
And the idea is that in conspiracy
circles from talking as them,
the idea is that he got over it after
awhile and needed to make a living.
Now talks about it constantly.
But Neil Armstrong never did.
The thing that's compelling is that
there was,
there were some,
there's some faking going on.
If you look at Gemini was in Gemini
Fifteen,
Michael Collins,
there's an image of Michael Collins when
they were testing some of the space,
uh,
walking stuff and some of the,
some of the things that they would do
to,
to walk outside of a spaceship.
Um,
they,
they had them all strapped up with
cables and they're just experimented
with these things.
They took that photograph and then
blacked out the background,
probably some overzealous pr agent.
And they were like in the pool right
here.
So what it is,
is like,
so the,
the first one is clearly he's,
you know,
in a studio and they're working on
things and just trying to understand how
all this stuff works.
And the second one,
they took the exact same photo and just
reversed it and blacked out the
background and they put.
This just doesn't mean that they didn't
go to the moon.
That just means that someone got ahold
of some photographs and faked it and
it's way more likely that there was more
of that going on then that people didn't
actually go to the moon.
Right?
Yeah.
The thing about going to the moon that's
really interesting is if they can go
again and they do go again and they find
all that stuff there,
you know,
then everybody has to just go,
oh yeah,
I guess we were all this stuff is.
I mean there's,
there's instruments on there that we
still monitor that the Apollo astronauts
left there.
Well then we monitor,
we monitor,
we shoot a laser up there and bounces
off.
Yeah.
But you know,
a laser will also bounce off the surface
of the moon.
Yeah.
But I don't think like they're not as
precise.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
But the Russians did that too with the
lunker hood.
One and two.
I believe they left a solar roof or
laser reflectors up there as well with
the unmanned Mr Japan has a video
footage as far as of like last week.
Yeah.
First out of the dark side of the.
So that's all fake too.
They will spaces fake dude.
There's no space.
Of course.
The moon's not even.
What is the moon?
If space is fake,
how did they explain that?
The images.
What's interesting is the images of the
dark side of the moon look exactly like
even like the landing and the whole
setup looks very similar to the Apollo
missions.
So they would have to either be in
cahoots or have worked together with
NASA.
Sound Studio?
Yeah.
To figure that he the old stuff.
Yeah,
look at it.
I mean this is the footage.
I mean,
God damn,
that looks eerily similar to what you
saw when the Apollo astronauts were
there.
I think it is entirely possible that
some of the,
um,
some of the practice film footage of
them,
you know,
on the surface or doing things turned
out to be pushed out as actual footage
of moon landings.
I think there was no television back
then.
There was no internet,
there was no vcrs,
there was no ability to review things
and watched them over again.
They projected something on television
one time and that was it.
So when they released pressed releases
and videos,
it's entirely possible that some of
those videos that got through were
actually just tests.
It's entirely possible that there was
just like the Michael Collins photos
that there was some fuckery going on.
You're dealing with so many human
beings,
you're dealing with.
So many people see an estimated 530
million people watch Armstrong's
televised image and heard his voice
describe.
Okay.
What does that.
It was broadcasted live like six hours
that day.
Yes.
Yeah.
It was actually broadcasted live on a
projection screen.
What they did was they didn't get a
straight feed.
They were filming the footage that was
on a projection screen.
That's how they did it and there's some
wonky
shit that looks like they fall down and
then they get pulled back up by wires
when they're on the surface of the moon,
but again,
I think how much of that is.
How much,
how much of that is actual footage of
them being on the moon and how much of
that is just test footage?
I mean,
I don't know.
Um,
I'm not sure about that,
but I think also,
uh,
I don't know Jack Shit about space
travel.
I don't know anything about
astrophysics.
I don't know anything about like what it
takes to land on the moon and come back
and whether or not.
And most of the people that talk about
this don't know that mythbusters did a
nice episode on did you know,
did we fake going to the moon?
And they showed a bunch of little
things.
For example,
on the moon with its gravity when you,
he goes something like that into the
dust,
you know,
the particles come up and they arch back
down in a certain way that it would be
different than if you are on earth so
that gravity is different.
Causes the dust to settle a different
way.
There was a bunch of things like that
that proves we were there.
Well,
it certainly proved that what took place
took place in a vacuum.
Yet,
not yet,
and a gravitational pull the same as the
moon.
The only,
um,
you've probably seen the feather in the
hammered drunk yet,
but you know,
you can do that here.
Well,
a yes in a vacuum.
Yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
but even a feather in a hammer,
even if it's,
it depends upon what kind of feather it
is,
but a feather and a hammer,
even if you just held them here and
dropped him on the ground,
they probably would landed a very
similar pace.
Favorite.
There's a spoof video about that.
We never went to the moon,
but couple of British comedians that,
that Kubrick thing is that with the
Kubrick one,
no appeal.
Uh,
what's their name?
I forget key and Peele key and Peele.
Yeah.
So the,
the,
the three of them are talking and you
know,
okay,
we're going to fake this whole thing.
And,
and,
uh,
and then the troubleshooters,
she's like,
well,
I'm now,
you know,
people are going to ask,
well how did we go to the moon?
And we're going to have to,
you know,
build a big rocket.
So we can say,
well we went into that big rocket and
they're like,
well how much would it cost to build
that big rocket?
Well,
it would be really expensive.
I mean we might as well just go to the
moon and then they started talking about
the expenses,
but we only have to feed three of them
if we go to the moon.
But if we shoot it as a shoot here in
the studio,
we're gonna have to have catering for
everybody to be super expensive.
It kind of goes on like that.
It's very funny.
That is funny.
But the conspiracy theorists would say,
well they couldn't send someone to the
moon so they had to fake it.
That's why they haven't been back.
Right.
They went from 1969 to 1973.
Is that what it was?
Six successful missions,
seven attempts.
Apollo 13 being the one that didn't make
it.
It's a,
it's a fun theory.
And what happened with me is I got way
better at spotting bullshit and learning
critical thinking skills and then paying
attention to all sides.
And I mean the,
the,
the real issue with something like that
is if someone could prove definitively
beyond a shadow of a doubt that not only
is it impossible that no one ever went
to the moon,
absolutely prove it.
That would be giant.
Yep.
I mean really would be.
I mean,
it would be a huge story,
but Ken,
is it even possible to do that?
You know,
the other analogy I use with the Wiki
leaks is there of all those tens of
thousand,
hundreds of thousands of memos and
papers and letters and government
documents.
There's not one mention anywhere of nine
slash 11 was an inside job,
you know,
and we had to allocate these funds to go
to this construction company who was
then seen working at the World Trade
Center.
But nothing like that.
So that in this case,
the absence of evidence is evidence of
absence didn't happen.
Not an inside job.
And the sign 11 one and something like
that would be true for the moon landing.
I mean,
all those people that worked on that,
not one of them saw anything and wanted
to write a book on 60 minutes.
The idea would be that there was
compartmentalized and that everyone,
like say if you're working on theo
rings,
you don't have access to the people that
are working on the thrusters.
If you have access to this,
you don't have access to that.
And that there was only a very small
group of people that controlled
everything.
Also 19,
69 was a very different environment in
terms of like what you get away with and
not get away with what you could say.
It's just,
it was really fun.
It was really fun to believe that they
fake going into the bone and I spent an
inordinate amount of time,
uh,
looking at it,
but I completely dropped it.
I dropped it after.
I just,
I paid attention to what I actually
know.
So,
but now you can kind of empathize with
those who do believe theories because.
Oh yeah,
but you want to hear a dumber one?
Yeah.
Here's a dumber one.
For the longest time,
like months,
I believed in a thing called rods.
Do you know the tiny little insects?
Yes.
Well they would it this guy put out this
duck is documentary that there was these
things flying so fast we couldn't see
them with the naked eye and that they
were like jellyfish,
like creatures that lived amongst us and
they had all this video footage of the.
Especially these people that were
jumping.
There were sky diving into this enormous
cave in Mexico and has there been sky
diving into this cave.
You see those things flying back and
forth and I was hook,
line and sinker.
I was like,
oh my God,
these things are around us all the time.
I was going outside and looking up
trying to spot them like imagine this,
these beings that are flying so fast so
we can't.
We can't see them.
The only way you capture it was on
camera and then a show called monster
quest cracked the riddle,
right?
They show that it's an a video artifact
and then if you have really high speed
camera,
you just see the insect,
but if you have low speed standard
definition video cameras,
it creates this artifact as these things
pass by very close to the lens at a high
rate of speed,
it elongates their video signal and it
makes them look like,
like this jellyfish type thing,
but it's really just a video artifact.
Yeah.
Again,
it's a good example of anomalies.
You know,
here's this weird video anomaly.
What is it about?
Just say,
I don't know.
Well,
if you don't know anything about video,
it's way easier.
Say,
oh,
that's the capture,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
take a camera,
put it outside.
You will capture these things.
Amazing,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
The other aspect of conspiracy theories
is cognitive dissonance.
That is we want the size of the event to
be matched by a cause that's equally
have that size.
So the analogy I use is you know the
Holocaust,
the worst genocide and human history
caused by the Nazis,
the worst bridge iem political regime
and human history.
There's a match there,
but if you say something like,
uh,
you know,
jfk,
the leader of the free world brought
down by who?
He Harvey Oswald.
Just some nobody,
you know,
there's this mismatch or nine slash 11
is huge thing by 19 guys with box
cutters.
Do you think that.
Doesn't Harvey Oswald acted alone?
Yeah.
What makes you think that?
All of the evidence and not none of the
evidence against anybody else and all of
the evidence against particularly him,
the general posner's book case closed.
And then the attorney.
What's his name?
That was the,
uh,
attorney
he,
his name.
He has a massive book where he lines up
every single one of the arguments by the
JFK conspiracy for example,
because just make a big deal about how
Oswaldo got a job at the book depository
building,
which just happened to be where the
parade just happened to be where the
parade route was going.
So you get to have a clear shot.
So it was positive that track down when
the White House determined even when
Kennedy was going to Dallas,
let alone what the parade route would
be.
An oswell already had the job there.
That's just chance.
So he knew it advanced bro.
He knew that you needed,
or do you think it's possible?
Well,
that Oswald was in cahoots?
No,
no,
no.
Why do you think that?
What about the magic bullet theory?
Well,
that's been settled by the fact that the
way it showed in the videos is that the
two seats are like this and at the
bullet has to do this.
Well.
In fact the seats were like that and
that connolly was.
You're explaining this.
I'm in audio form just when you're
saying.
Oh yeah,
so it's like stadium seating.
One's elevated above the other.
That's right.
Yeah.
So the bullet actually,
when it passes through the neck through
Kennedy's neck and then hits Connolly's
shoulder it,
it is already moving.
We get to his wrist at fraction is
roasted,
right?
The.
This has been tested and tested and
tested.
Well,
sort of.
Here's,
here's my issue with it.
There's a couple issues.
One on the,
on the pro side,
the idea that bullets we'll take a
straight path is ridiculous.
I've,
I've talked to hunters that have shot
animals in the front and had a bullet
come out the same side.
They shot it and it ricocheted off bones
and came out like the front of the
animal,
like bullets take weird paths when they
hit things in particular.
Uh,
so to arrows they take as a person who's
well versed in firearms and shot animals
and hunted this.
You don't.
Sometimes the bullet goes straight
through and sometimes it hits bones and
wacky things happen.
Things deflect.
But on the negative side they always
distort.
Bullets always distort,
particularly when they hit bone,
but bothered me was that they found that
bullet in Connolly's Gurney.
When they brought him to the hospital,
they just conveniently found this
bullet.
Aha,
we have it.
This is the bullet that matches the same
rifle and but it wasn't pristine.
It was flattened.
Barely.
If you look at that bullet,
that bullet does nothing like a bullet
that hit bone.
When bullets hit bone,
they mushroom,
they balloon,
they bend,
they distort wildly.
They don't come out looking like that.
They come out looking like that when you
shoot them into water or when you shoot
them into like feathers,
they don't come out looking like that
under normal circumstances when they
shattered the bone of two different
people.
Well to you know that for sure.
No,
I do not know that for sure.
But um,
one thing I do know a lot about is I
know quite a bit about what bullets look
like when they hit things.
I've looked into this pretty extensively
and I've talked to a lot of people in
law enforcement,
military hunters,
and none of them believed that that
bullet hit bones,
shattered.
Bones came out looking like that.
Is it possible that that bullet was the
only bullet ever in the history of the
world that did do that?
Yeah,
it might be.
Okay.
So we're getting kind of caught up in
the weeds of the anomalies.
What about this?
Just a bullet.
Oswald himself had attempted to
assassinate a general name Walker six
months before with his rifle and a
handgun and he went over to the house.
He took a shot through the guys when he
saw him at the desk,
took a shot,
missed him.
He told his wife about it.
I'm a revolutionary.
I'm trying to start stuff.
Don't get me wrong.
I'm not saying that Oswald was innocent.
I'm not.
I mean,
I think it's very possible that Oswald
did shoot at the president.
He might've even hit the president.
It's very possibly that some other
people were involved as well,
who,
I don't know.
Say this is the problem,
but wait a minute,
why is it a problem if you don't know
who they are?
Just because you don't know who they are
doesn't mean it didn't exist,
but why do we need to postulate extra
people?
Because of all the gunshots that
happened in a short amount of time.
The fact that the reason why they came
up with the theory of the magic bullet
in the first place,
because they had to account for a bullet
that hit a curb underneath the overpass.
Do you know that?
Right?
Yeah.
Okay.
There's three.
There's okay.
If you know why they came out with them.
I.
Yeah,
I've been there.
Do you know why they came up with,
but it's short.
I mean,
it's right there.
You could not miss the point was that,
that's sort of true.
Yeah.
It's not a far shot.
And he was a pretty good marksman.
A positive track down is.
We're not talking about that.
We're talking about the reason why they
came up with the magic bullet theory in
the first place.
Do you know what?
Well,
I thought it was because,
uh,
of the alignment of the seats.
No,
because they had to attribute three
shots.
They had to figure out in one of them
they were,
they were thinking,
well,
they all have these wounds.
Came from three bullets,
but then they found a bullet that had
hit the curb on the underside and got
checked into a hospital because he was
hitting the ricochet.
So there's a curb that they proved was
hit with a bullet.
There was a bullet hole in the granite
or whatever the fuck the curbs made out
of it.
Hit this guy.
He went to the hospital.
So he was hit with a ricochet.
So they knew that one bullet had not hit
the president,
and so they had to attribute all of
these wounds to one bullet.
Now they had one bullet that landed into
his neck,
another bullet that hit him in the head.
So how do these three bullets cause a
wound timely as well.
Then they came up with the map.
There's,
there's the bullet look at that bullet,
but you have to look at this at the end.
It's flattened.
If you look at it from the end.
No,
it's not.
Look at this.
Under no circumstances do I feel that
this bullet could hit a risks and still
not be deformed.
We proved that by experiments as a chief
consultant in wound ballistics for the
US army who supervised tests for the
Warren Commission.
Here's the thing,
I don't.
I don't necessarily think that there was
some grand conspiracy,
but I do think it's entirely possible
that someone took that posthumously,
took that rifle and wanting to pin it on
Lee Harvey Oswald definitively.
Look,
there's people that do things when they
know someone's guilty and they plant
evidence.
Mark Furhman did that with Oj Simpson.
They found his glove and they,
they planted evidence and there was one
of the reasons why Oj got off because
there was some sort of conspiring to
make it look like he was,
you know,
it was the.
The evidence was a clear path.
They could have just taken that rifle
and look,
could've been that Oswald did it alone.
It's possible,
but also could have been this.
Some other people were shooting at them
too.
It could have been that they had decided
to have oswald be a part of this and
when Jack Ruby ran in and shot them,
that doesn't look a little suspicious at
some guy with ties to the mob gets right
up to this guy who just shot the
president and shoots him like why?
That's never shot before.
Do it publicly.
Posner talks about Ruby's character and
who he was,
major kennedy supporter,
a running with some bad dudes,
some bread bad andres there in Texas and
he was a gun owner.
A security wasn't anything like it is
now.
He really could just walk right in like
he did.
It's possible,
but it's also possible that that guy
owed something to the mob and this is
what they told them to do.
Are you going to get rid of that guy?
No one's going to care.
They're going to be happy.
Fuck,
that guy just shot the president who
seems so it seems like people want it to
be one way or the other and they want,
they want this case closed and be that
way.
I mean,
Lincoln was assassinated by a conspiracy
and that was evident pretty quickly
afterwards and they rounded them up.
Uh,
you know,
World War One was launched by a
conspiracy with the assassination of
Franz Ferdinand by a Serbian group of,
called the black hand,
the group of nationalists while we were
talking about the Vietnam War to the
Gulf of Tonkin incident.
False flag.
So these things do happen.
They're all false legs.
There are conspiracies to assassinate
foreign leaders.
Uh,
you know,
hits,
wrote this book.
I'm Kissinger as a war criminal,
uh,
that,
you know,
all the shenanigans.
We were doing it in South America with
dictators.
There were back in this take Taylor,
because he's the son of a bitch,
but he's our son of a bitch versus this
guy and we're going to sas and a Castro.
All the stuff that came out that Johnson
tried to cover up that came out in the
Pentagon papers about Kennedy plotting
to have Castro assassinated.
That's a kind of conspiracies that this.
Absolutely this does happen.
The question is,
did it happen in that particular case or
this one or a year and the evidence,
in my opinion,
after reading particularly Gerald Posner
is booked a case closed.
It's funny.
Internet meme that went around last week
of a guy who dies,
goes to heaven and God says you,
you've been such a good fellow your
whole life.
I'll grant you one wish.
She can ask me anything.
He said,
alright,
who killed Kennedy?
And God said it was Lee Harvey Oswald,
acting alone using his own Kokona rifle
and the guy goes,
this goes higher up than I thought.
That's funny,
man.
Did you ever read David Lifton's novel
or a book about it rather?
Yeah.
Best evidence.
So I didn't read the whole book when I
was researching this back in the
nineties when after the Oliver Stone
film came out,
because after that,
when that came out,
I thought,
man,
if only half of this or 10 percent of
this is true,
it's definitely a conspiracy.
But then there are websites dedicated to
everything he got wrong there.
Well,
he made people up like the General
Donald Sutherland character.
That guy doesn't even exist.
He just used him as a theatrical tool,
very distorting film.
And that film is such a powerful medium.
It's hard to overcome that.
Well,
that movie in particular,
you've got Kevin Costner,
who's the good guy.
Everybody loves it.
Yeah.
I mean that is a Jack Lemmon,
Walter Matthau too.
Crazy movie.
And it really has you believing that
there's some sort of a continuous into
the lip back into the left people.
Well,
here's the thing about that though.
I've looked at that over and over again.
Yes it is back into the left,
but the spray kind of comes out the
front.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
It kinda comes out the front.
And one thing that does happen when
people or things get shot is you have
nerves and nerves react and things.
Things do weird,
weird results in your body when if you
get hit by something,
it doesn't get his hands come up like
that.
Well,
he's grabbing his neck.
Apparently.
That was the other thing was there was a
difference in the autopsy results from
Bethesda,
Maryland versus in Dallas,
Texas,
Dallas,
Texas.
They attributed the throat,
wound to a frontal shot at something.
Hit him in the front.
And then the Bethesda,
Maryland,
they said that it was a trait wound.
They,
uh,
they opened them up to clear his
breathing pathway.
And then the conspiracy theorists will
say,
why would you clear the breathing
pathway of a guy who doesn't have a
brain spraying was shot out of his head.
I just don't like when people say they
know one way or another,
we harvey Oswald acted alone.
Fuck.
Could you know,
there was a bunch of bull.
There was also bullet fragments and
Connolly's wrist that weren't missing
from the bullet itself.
The bullet itself,
whether you think it's pristine or not,
it's still,
it's not missing a lot of fragments and
there's fragments in Connolly's body
that they.
You could detect an x ray,
there's x rays in his wrist and you
could see the little pieces of the.
I don't know what the explanation for
that.
The fact that,
I don't know.
I'm not the world's expert on this
stuff.
People want to clean it up.
That's what I don't like.
They want to clean it up or they want to
muddy it up instead of like looking at
it a hundred percent objectively,
they want one thing or another.
I think it's entirely possible that Lee
Harvey Oswald,
it's either to me they want to say,
this is the.
These are the two narratives.
Lee Harvey Oswald was a patsy.
He had nothing to do with the government
set him up or he acted alone,
but why?
Why couldn't he have been evolved in it?
You know,
he obviously was involved in some shady
characters.
The guy spent a ton of time in Russia,
came back over here very easily.
Even though the Cold War was going on.
There's a lot of weird stuff.
He might've very well been some sort of
a government informant or working in
cahoots with the government if that's
the case,
and he did shoot candidate or shoot at
Kennedy,
who's to say that he wasn't with other
people and they killed him because this
guy was going to go to jail and he was
going to start talking.
When they arrested him,
he said,
I'm a Patsy,
patsy and then blam.
He's dead up.
We got them and that's it.
Wrap it up tight.
It wasn't until the Zapruder film that
people really started to question and I
think that was.
It might've been 10 years later.
Right.
We've talked about,
you know,
the whole history of the Zapruder film,
how it was released.
The Geraldo Rivera show,
right.
Crazy,
Dick Gregory comedian brought the film
footage to the Geraldo Rivera show and
showed it on television for the First
Time magazine,
but the rights to life magazine had the
rights and didn't do anything with it.
They kept it for more than a decade.
Dick Gregory got ahold of the actual
film footage and premiered it on the
Geraldo Rivera shall I want to say it
was like 1971 or 72 or something like
that,
so it was way,
way after the assassination that the
American,
what was it?
Seventy five is 12 years old.
That's crazy.
Seventy five,
so all those years later and then people
got a chance to see the footage and they
were like,
wow,
this is not how it was described to us
at all and it made people skeptical.
There's a good Nova show on ballistics
in the head and testing the rifle and
could you shoot that many times and that
many seconds and so on,
and it's pretty cool.
To me,
it's pretty convincing.
The problem with me is I know too much
about what happens when bullets hit
bones.
I don't buy that.
That was the bullet I do.
Look,
I think they could've just dropped that
bullet off.
It doesn't mean that Lee Harvey Oswald
didn't do it.
Thinking about that bullet though,
is that there might be some fuckery
involved and the David Liftin book was.
That was the book that got me into
conspiracies.
That fucking book.
God dammit.
If I could go back and not read it.
I bombed on stage because of that book
you did?
Yeah.
Well it was my fault,
but I've read that book the day I was
performing and I was freaking out
because I was like 24 or something like
that.
I was like,
oh,
this is crazy.
They killed the president and I was so
naive and
I was like really bummed out when I went
onstage and then I realized like,
oh,
you can't.
Like I didn't know any better.
I've only been doing comedy for three
years and you can't go on stage.
Bombed out if you've got to get your
head together.
You can't just say the jokes and not
have some emotional attachment to them,
but that book highlights what it was was
lifted,
was a bookkeeper and an accountant,
I believe,
and he was hired to do something with
the Warren Commission report and in it
because he found some contradictions and
he went over the entire Warren
Commission report,
which is an enormous,
enormous publication,
and he found all of these problems,
all of these problems in the Warren
Commission report and all of these
contradictions.
And it was his determination after
reading everything in writing his book,
he thought that the conclusion they
made,
they made before the fact and that they
wrote all this stuff to sort of Vr the
backup,
their conclusion that it wasn't based
entirely on an objective version of the
facts of the event itself.
And his,
his take was,
there was a conspiracy.
Well,
it's launched a mini industry of books.
It,
man,
think about all the money that's been
made off of the Kennedy assassination.
If you go down the rabbit hole with this
stuff,
do you ever see the Jesse Ventura
version of it?
Uh,
he believes that he
is the best.
It was on his computer spirits he show.
Yeah,
he's out there.
Oh yeah.
He believes it.
Yeah.
He was like,
no one could have made shocked.
They definitely could have made that
shot.
It's a rifle.
It's not that far.
Just because someone gets lucky doesn't
mean they can't get lucky.
Like people get lucky all the time.
People flip a coin and it lands on heads
a mile away.
I mean,
you know,
you could throw a coin,
you could,
you could throw a coin out of a
helicopter,
you know,
you could say this is going to be heads
when it lands and it can be heads.
You can get lucky.
Right.
It really is possible.
Well this assassination of Franz
Ferdinand that triggered the first world
war.
This.
Yes.
Okay.
They,
they messed up.
I had like seven of them and they met in
secret and they got their weapons that
morning and so on.
And a couple of them,
chicken,
dad,
somebody else cut last.
It's just like three of them there.
Somebody threw a hand grenade,
missed,
rolled into the car behind the friends
for non and and they got hurt and went
to the hospital and he's like,
oh fuck,
there's not giving my speech,
let's go to the hospital and visit,
see how he's doing.
So they double back like half an hour
later they doubled back and come back
down the same route.
And the guy who had missed,
he was just sitting there on the curb.
It's like,
Oh fuck,
here they are.
Bam.
Yeah,
pure luck.
Pure luck.
Yeah.
That doesn't happen.
I mean that,
that history turns more on that kind of
thing.
Then on carefully orchestrated,
perfectly executed plot.
Sure.
It certainly can.
But you know,
the,
the idea that,
um,
uh,
I'm,
I've always found it offensive.
The idea that there's no way Oswald
could have hit him.
Like people say that like there's no
way.
There's no way you're out of your.
You never
shot anything.
That's crazy.
I can make that shot.
One hundred percent.
Yep.
I will.
Look,
if you have a rifle with a scope and a
guy is a hundred yards away,
you tell them you can't shoot him.
Right?
That's crazy time.
That's crazy.
Talk or the rifle was out of La.
That was the other thing.
They said the scope wasn't lined up
correctly.
Here's the thing,
folks,
if you have a rifle,
okay,
and this has happened to me before,
and you drop the rifle,
the scope gets damaged,
it gets moved.
It's a very sensitive thing,
like when you're talking about something
that goes faster than the speed of sound
of bullets,
boom,
firing out of a rifle,
you have that.
That is going incredibly fast and to be
able to get that radical exactly on
where you think that bullet's going to
hit requires a lot of adjustments.
When you go to the range,
they set up a lead sled.
You put your rifle down on this sled so
you're not holding the rifle,
and by the way,
we oddball wasn't holding it either.
The idea was that he had it rested,
right?
Which makes it much more steady and much
more easier to make an accurate shot.
So you set up this rifle on the lead
sled and it's usually 100 yards or 200
yards,
whatever,
however farther distances to the target,
you squeeze,
squeeze,
boom.
That trigger goes off and you see that
the bullet is low and to the left by a
couple of inches,
you make an adjustment on the scope.
If you drop that rifle,
that scope gets knocked the adjustments
out the window.
So the idea that there's like a perfect
chain of command between Lee Harvey
Oswald,
pulling that trigger and that scope
never got rattled at all.
No,
but the conspiracy theorists want you to
think there's no way he could've made
that shot.
That scope wasn't even lined up.
Good.
How the fuck do you know?
No.
You don't know.
Like anybody who knows anything about
rifles,
knows there's no way you could know,
because if all you'd have to do is whack
it here,
I'm going to bring you the rifle and
just bump it with your elbow funny.
Knock it into a wall when you're handing
it to someone and that scope's going to
be off,
right?
So you then you take it to a range.
We're going to prove definitively that
he could have never made this shot
because this scope is off.
Look,
it's six inches to the left.
Wow.
Case closed right now.
There's no way people know whether or
not that scope was on when he was
pulling that trigger.
There's no way.
You know,
when I went to Dealey Plaza,
it's so big and our public imagination,
it's not.
It's not like this is it.
It's tiny and so small.
And then you go up to the museum and
you're on the sixth floor,
positive,
the book depository,
and you look down and they have an x,
the two xs in the street.
And you think that's just right there.
Dude,
I can shoot that with an arrow.
I bet you could.
I can.
Yeah.
I guarantee if you give me some time,
you give me some time if you put a
target right where that thing was right
where that a lincoln was and,
and you put me in that window,
I guarantee you I hit that target with a
bow,
right?
Like the idea that you couldn't.
And I'm holding it.
No rest.
The idea that you couldn't do that with
a,
with a rifle,
right?
You turn it certainly could.
Lee Harvey Oswald certainly could have
done it.
He certainly couldn't have shot at
Kennedy.
He was a crazy fuck.
Lee Harvey Oswald was involved in a lot
of shady shit.
It wasn't like he was just
some dentists somewhere toward the
second reading depositary he scored the
second highest marksmanship.
There it is.
Right?
Right here to here.
Right.
Dude,
that's so small.
That was such a short distance.
Then the other question I had when
you're coming up Houston street and
going left,
I always wondered why he didn't shoot
him there when the car's coming right at
him.
What was the other window?
He was in the window on the left hand
side.
He was over there.
No,
no,
no.
It's over here.
Yeah,
it's right there.
That's where he shot them from that
window there.
Yup.
So I always wondered why he didn't shoot
him when the car was coming right at
him.
Because that would have been a cleaner
shot.
It seems to me head on you mean?
Yeah.
Yeah,
um,
maybe you want to shoot him in the back
of the head.
Does it have like a sniper?
It's maybe panic.
It's that upper right?
Yeah,
at that one.
Yeah.
Wow.
When we drove through it,
when the last time,
not last time was in Dallas a couple
times ago,
but when we drove through it,
it's like,
it's eerie.
You're like,
wow,
this is.
It all happened right here.
I've been twice there and there's always
a conspiracy people walking around there
looking for a tip.
I gave this guy 10 bucks and go,
all right,
give me the whole story.
And Oh,
he was very entertaining here.
Here's the Grassy Knoll,
the picket fence.
And he had another one about this man.
He took the manhole cover off because
there was somebody down here in the
manhole.
Oh,
lopped up.
Bam.
Shot him,
went back down to the metal favorite DM
conspiracy is they believe that the
driver turnaround shot.
That's the best way.
Yeah.
Those are the spaces.
Fake people.
You're always going to get a bunch of
really wacky conspiracies whenever
anything happens in the news,
whatever it is,
you know,
anything and everything,
particularly if it's big and famous.
Again,
back to this cognitive dissonance like
Princess Di,
you know,
cause of death,
drunk driving,
speeding.
No seatbelt.
You know,
tens of thousands of people died that
was drunk.
He was drunk yet the driver of her car
I didn't know that.
He was partially drunk.
He was tipsy drunk.
Wow.
I didn't.
I didn't know.
Yeah,
that's right.
So drunk driving,
speeding.
And,
and she wasn't wearing a seatbelt.
Why wasn't she wearing a seatbelt?
So,
I mean,
that's it,
but it doesn't feel like print.
Someone like Princess Di should die the
way tens of thousands of Americans die
in automobiles every year.
It seems like there should be,
you know,
the [inaudible] and the royal family,
uh,
the Arabs and the Palestinians that
everybody was involved.
Well,
here's an example of an absolute
conspiracy that we know is,
was a conspiracy.
Jamal Sogi.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
A good example.
This kind of stuff does happen.
This is a real case.
That guy was murdered,
he went to the Saudi embassy in Turkey.
They had him set up,
they flew in 15 people,
including a guy who was a,
he was a forensics expert and he was an
expert in forensics,
forensics evidence,
and they think that he was there to make
sure that there was nothing left behind.
They,
this is the official story is they
strangled him,
caught him up,
and the,
there's even recordings apparent that
goes all the way to the listen to the
top.
Saudi Arabia.
What does this,
Jamie,
that's the last video seeing him.
Oh,
the body double video of him walking in
and then it's the last time you've seen.
Yeah,
he,
he entered into there and there's 15
different dudes that were waiting for
them.
They killed them,
chopped him up.
And there's videos of those guys leaving
with suitcases and they say that the
suitcases had his body in them chopped
up.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's real,
but that's also,
you know,
Saudi Arabia,
they can get away with some pretty
sketchy shit and it seems like nothing's
going to happen.
Right?
Like people,
few people got fired.
Well,
I have to say on this that I'm Michael
Moore's film on nine slash 11.
He made the point,
I was the first I'd seen make the point
that the Saudi Arabia family got out of
the United States on 9:12 when all
flights were canceled and that Bush let
you know.
And now here we see that trump doesn't
want to condemn the Saudis because
they're our allies.
So there's a bunch of shit in there.
It goes all the way back to nine slash
11.
And we know the Saudis support,
uh,
bankrolled most of the 19 hijackers.
Yeah.
So that's the kind of conspiracy that we
should be paying attention to.
Not that Bush was involved and made it
happen in the secret.
This is the kind of shit that really
happens in politics,
you know,
people are our banking each other,
so we have to be nice to each other and
overlook it.
You know,
like when trump said,
you know,
Putin,
Putin murders people,
oh well everybody does it.
What
we do some terrible things to,
and,
and that's true.
And it's true.
And you know,
I guess he's got a point,
but the.
Yeah,
it's just so there's so much money,
so much money involved with Saudi
Arabia.
In this article I was writing,
I cited a criminologist,
manual eisner in a study of 1500
monarchs in 45 monarchies across Europe.
Between add 600 and 1800,
found that about 15 percent of them 227
were assassinated chorus punting to
homicide rate of about a thousand per
100,000 ruler years,
10 times the background rate.
So in other words,
assassinations in history are pretty
common.
This is how power often changes hands
before liberal democracies spread.
And after 19 seventies,
this was not uncommon though,
so we shouldn't be surprised that people
believe this kind of stuff because you
know there's some truth to that thing is
unsettling to folks because what he was
killed for,
they think,
well there's.
There's two different versions of it,
right?
There's this film.
He was killed for criticizing the Saudi
Arabian government,
but he was also.
There was also that he was criticized
because he was aware or he was killed
rather because he was aware of some spy
software that's being utilized and that
if he wrote a story about this spy
software being utilized by the Saudi
Arabian
government,
that it would be a huge disaster.
Mm hmm.
Could be.
Yeah.
I mean there's more.
We,
I'm sure there's a lot we don't know.
So here's my,
a concession to conspiracy theories.
When you get elected president,
they take you in the back room and they
go,
okay,
here's what's actually going on.
Right?
Oh Shit.
I can't close Gitmo close.
Get bumped because no one will take
those bed dudes.
Okay,
but,
but pull the troops out of Afghanistan
can't pull the troops out of Afghanistan
if we do that.
Here's what happens.
Oh Shit.
But we don't know this.
We know this.
And I think that something like that
does go on,
maybe not quite so secretly,
but just that you know,
you and I don't need to know.
These things need to know basis.
And,
and the president does.
When their candidates,
they say,
oh,
whatever they say to get elected,
and then they get in there and go,
oh,
okay,
I didn't realize that the Saudis are
doing this and this and this and we need
them for these six reasons over here.
Okay.
They did this bad thing and if we
condemn them then they're not going to
do these things over here,
so I better lay off the condemnation.
That kind of stuff I suspect does happen
a lot.
I think you're correct.
I think I suspect the same thing.
Now what's fascinating to me about trump
is that he doesn't seem to care at all
about violating protocol or about
releasing information that he probably
shouldn't be there.
He's already accidentally released top
secret information.
I would just feel like if he knew for
sure some,
some stuff,
like he would be the last guy you would
want to trust with that.
Right.
I know,
but you know this thing about him
wanting to pull the troops out of Syria.
There's gotta be another story behind.
They're like,
you know,
Putin maybe.
He said,
look,
we gotta take care of our business here
in Syria.
We're going to take care of Americans
over here and you get your trump tower
in red square when,
when I'm gone or whatever,
you know,
there's some kind of.
That kind of stuff is the sort of thing
that will come out in a equivalent of a
Wiki leaks in 20 years will go,
oh,
like the Gulf of Tonkin.
Oh,
okay.
That's what happened.
What do you think conspiracy theory that
says that trump has some video of trump
getting peed on or people
that was published in like some serious
newspapers.
Yup.
There's so much of this stuff that I
just can't keep track of it.
I mean,
don't you think with him though too?
They'll,
they'll like,
read more than willing to put stuff like
that out there because they don't like
them.
So they'll pull that trigger a little
bit quicker maybe.
Yep.
But you know,
during the Bush administration,
people hated George W dot Bush and hated
him as much as they hate trump.
Uh,
no.
I think now they're going,
oh,
we would love to have George W Bush
back.
I feel like they just thought he was
incompetent.
Although directly Putin does not deny
possessing compromising material on
trump.
Uh,
but,
but what did he actually say?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yes,
this is about the pee tape says Matthew
Yglesias voc.
What is it from Volvo?
It's vox moving
doesn't mean a.
He probably didn't understand what they
were saying.
Speaks Russian,
right?
I Dunno.
Um,
do you find it odd that the,
these conspiracies not only do,
it seems like it's a part of our,
our mind,
the way our brains work,
our collective mindset is that we tend
to be attracted to conspiracies and we
tend to hope that those or true more
than we hope a simple explanation
exists.
Yeah.
Well,
it depends.
It depends on who your group is and do
they have power or not.
So we know from studies that people that
are out of power tend to consume,
can concoct conspiracy theories about
the,
those in power.
And the moment they get empowered,
they drop the conspiracy theories and
the ones that are out.
Uh,
so you're going to get more conspiracy
theories about Republicans when the
Democrats are out of power from left
leaning people and vice versa.
It blacks are more likely to think that
the CIA planted crack cocaine in the
inner cities and,
and,
and those sorts of things.
Conservatives are more likely to fear
big government conspiracies.
Liberals are more likely to fear big
corporate conspiracies.
It,
there may be elements of truth in all of
these things,
but the ones your latch onto have to do
with how much power you perceive the
other guy has that you don't have and
therefore they must be doing something
to get that,
that I can't do.
I'm on the outside and so we tend to
misperceive how much control and power
people really have in positions of
power.
Ceos,
politicians and so on.
Usually they don't have as much control
and power as we think they do and people
that get in there,
they go,
oh,
I can't,
I can't.
I don't have this kind of controller
power.
I thought I would when I got here,
but obviously I don't do too many things
that have to do checks.
And balances that are in place,
so you can't do these things on your
own.
You really need a group of people to
conspire along with you.
So you mean to have these frank
discussions with some sort of an
understanding that you have to keep this
a secret,
right?
Maura?
Yeah.
In other words,
like 12 guys in London are going to
control the world's economy.
How are they going to do that?
I mean,
who do you call to start a war and cause
inflation or whatever.
More likely.
It's like in the Cuban missile crisis
where you have jockeying back and forth,
back and forth,
back and forth.
Okay,
look,
we're going to give you the missiles in
Turkey.
If you take the missiles out of Cuba.
And it just ends up being some boring
little thing that dissolves the tension.
That could have been world war three.
It's like wow,
just this little thing.
And so much of history turns on those
little,
you know.
So in a way we got lucky there,
but not just luck.
I mean,
Kennedy and Khrushchev both wanted to
untie the knot,
you know,
crew shift sent a memo to Kennedy saying
you have pulled on this rope and I have
pulled on this rope and I don't know if
either of us can untie it,
but here's an idea.
That's when he floated the,
you take the out of Turkey
and,
and I was just watching this netflix
documentary on this and there was a
thing about Castro Santa memo to crew
chef saying light them up,
you know,
comrade,
we are ready to die for the cause.
You can just nuke all of Cuba and nuke
America.
I don't care.
We're ready to die.
And Khrushchev Khrushchev apparently was
like,
holy fuck,
this guy's a madman.
We're not going to do that.
And so that's true.
He's ready to new Cuba.
Yeah.
Jesus,
where's that memo?
Uh,
they,
they talked about this in this duck.
The netflix.
Yeah.
Anyway,
so this was during the times of
operation northwoods when they were
gonna blow up a drone jetliner and blame
it on the Cubans arm,
Cuban friendlies to attack Montana Mo
Bay.
And use it as a motivation to get us
into war.
That Castro is a fascinating case
because that guy kept that place 90
miles away from Miami.
He kept that place running on his own
until he died.
That was crazy.
Really.
It's crazy that he was able to pull that
off.
Well,
he had a lot of support,
economic support from Russia otherwise.
And that would not have succeeded,
but still it's so nuts that he was so
close and he was running a military
dictatorship.
Essentially a boat ride away.
Yeah.
I was just in Moscow a few months ago
for a conference since I went to visit
their world war two museum,
what we would call a world war two
museum,
just massive building it and they call
it the Great Patriotic War Museum.
And the whole thing is kind of attribute
to Russia liberated Europe from the
Nazis.
Yup.
This is current.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
I mean this is from their perspective,
they lost 27 million people.
You Americans,
you know,
500,000 nothing.
Right.
And from their perspective.
And you go to Berlin right next to the
victory museum.
Look at that.
Yeah.
It's called the victory museum.
Well,
there it is.
The Museum of the Great Patriotic War is
a history museum located in Muskoka yet.
And they have this room with these
chains hanging down with little crystal
balls at the end of them that represent
the 27 million people.
And it's,
it's,
it's very moving.
Go back to that.
That right there is good.
Look how beautiful that place.
It's quite stunning.
And each of those rooms that you go
into,
it's like a diagram of some battle that
they fought.
We,
I think it's good for us to know this,
to recognize from their perspective
they,
they won the war,
not the British American and French.
We did a little bit from their
perspective,
but the fact that they lost so many
people,
27 million.
What's going on with that picture?
I don't remember.
Fucked up looking at the present.
That's a weird picture.
Um,
I mean they have a point in terms of
their contribution in terms of the loss
of lives.
Yeah.
That's A.
I mean every country has its
perspectives in that regard,
which is why it's good to some history,
so you know
what other people are thinking and what
they went through.
Well,
it's again though,
it's very similar to what we're talking
about earlier in terms of the
distribution of the news.
It would be very nice if there was one
absolute news source you can trust with
no slant on it whatsoever.
When it comes to the distribution of
history,
it's of course always written in a way
that favors the people that are writing
it.
Yeah.
I was just talking to Rachel Kleinfeld.
I have a podcast now,
a few months.
That's six months now.
It's science salon podcast.
Yeah.
Well it's sort of an extension of our
old caltech lecture series,
but instead of lectures we're not doing
dialogue you called so people can see
science salon,
science salon.
Yep.
So just skeptic.com.
It's okay.
So I'm interviewing are dialoguing with
Rachel Kleinfeld.
She has a new book called a savage order
and it's about failed states and what
happens to them and why corruption
spread so quickly.
And then how to basically squelch that.
So like after the Soviet Union fell
apart,
you know,
all these mobs basically took over and
it's like the Russian mafia,
the Republic of Georgia fell apart
fairly quickly and then,
you know,
so one of the reasons people apparently
like Putin is he kind of came in and,
and,
and squelched all that.
And,
and maybe one of his points of
popularity is that at least we have one
bad guy who's got kind of keeping an
order instead of all these little
mafioso type gangs.
And uh,
and I said,
so if he actually held an election,
he might win.
It's like,
it's hard to say because we don't have a
good source of what the Russian people
really like.
We have the Russian media saying the
Russian people love Putin.
Okay.
Do we know that's an accurate survey?
Is Pretty astonishing.
What kind of a control he has over the
country though?
Yeah,
it's powerful.
I went to visit a lot.
I saw Lenin's tomb and the Mazda Liam
there,
he's still still looking pretty waxy,
uh,
to me.
Oh,
that's right.
You can actually see his body or what's
the.
His body.
Yeah.
What's left of it yet another netflix
series.
I just binge watched Trotsky.
It's called Trotsky and this is a
Russian made film.
It's a drama and um,
it's really good and it really shows.
It's interesting because he,
Trotsky was on the outs all the way
until just recently because Stalin had
him sas donated and then on had him
literally airbrushed out of photographs
because for awhile it was Lenin and
Stalin.
Trotsky is the big three and then when
Lenin had a stroke it was like,
okay,
so Stalin and Trotsky,
who's going to take over when the boss
is gone?
And uh,
so they kind of showed how that
happened.
And again,
conspiracy.
It's all conspiracy.
No one knows what's really going on
here.
You've been in this business,
this debunking conspiracy conspiracy's
in the skeptic business for quite a long
time.
Do you feel like there is any
improvement in the critical thinking
skills of people and their ability
to recognize the fallacies and the flaws
in the way they're approaching these
things?
Hard to say.
Confirmation bias there,
less of that now than before,
like to think we're having an influence.
There is some studies that show,
you know,
fewer people believe in these pseudo
sciences and quackery and paranormal,
but it's not.
The declines are not that dramatic over
say the last few decades.
There are deprogramming bias,
deprogramming studies and programs in
which you can teach people about the
confirmation bias in the hindsight bias
and so on.
The problem with those is they work
really well to teach people how to spot
the biases and other people.
They're really good at that.
But then you say,
well,
what about you?
Oh know,
fortunately I'm above all that.
There's a blind spot that's called the
blind spot bias.
You can't see your own bias,
but you can see it in other people.
Um,
so the,
um,
the reason these studies are done is
because we have a problem with climate
change.
We have climate deniers.
How do we get people who don't know
anything about it to shift from?
I'm a skeptic too.
I'm a believer and it shows,
it turns out just piling on facts isn't
going to do it.
No people's identity are trapped in
their initial initial statements.
If they think that nine slash 11 was a
conspiracy there,
their identity is somehow inexorably
connected to this conspiracy being a
fact,
and then you argue it as if you're
arguing your own value.
It's a really weird thing that happens
when people start talking about ideas.
If the you,
you,
you've very rarely find people that are
disconnected from their ideas to the
point where you could point out that
something's incorrect and they go,
oh,
thank you.
I didn't know that.
Like most people aren't really that
confident now,
or are they just look at it the wrong.
It feels like a personal attack on them.
Also as,
uh,
if it's a belief or claim or theory or
whatever affiliated with a political or
moral or religious value,
the people autocorrect in their brains
when they hear global warming,
they hear liberalism,
communism,
capitalism,
control of the market,
big government.
And I'm against those things so that
global warming things got to be faults.
That is one of the weirder aspects of
tribal thinking,
right?
Pink or makes the point that,
uh,
Al Gore's film an inconvenient truth was
a terrible thing for the environmental
movement because at associated global
climate change with liberalism,
the Democrats and all that,
it's like,
oh,
okay,
I see what's going on.
It's that Al Gore left liberal stuff.
That's right.
Yeah.
Well in,
in,
in a sense he's right.
And then in another sense it was also
the amount of profit that alcor made
both from that and from some other
endeavors that he has.
They said that he's one of the first
green billionaires.
So God,
Jesus,
what's his carbon footprint is around a
private jet everywhere.
He's talking about the world.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's screwy.
Yeah.
But that's,
you know,
there's,
everything's messy.
People are messy,
right?
So we're very tribal.
We commit to political parties or
religious beliefs and we stick by them
pretty closely,
a pretty tightly.
And the facts get filtered through
those.
Understandably,
um,
you know,
what to do about it,
that's,
that's under debate it.
Same thing with the atheist debating.
How do we get people to leave religion?
Well,
just there's 100 ways you know,
Leah Remini on her show on scientology.
Anyone watching that would think,
okay,
I'm not joining this church,
and so if you had a thousand of those
for bad beliefs,
hopefully we see that shift.
I would love it if there was some sort
of a secular option of community driven,
ethics driven,
morality driven friendship driven thing
where people could go and instead
worship,
maybe just appreciate life and sort of
confirm some of the best aspects of,
of community and culture and who we are
and do it in a place where it makes you
really conscious of it.
So because I think there's,
there's some,
some real benefit to people going to
church and everyone in the community
community dresses up nice and you sort
of agreeing,
hey,
we're committed to being civil and to
being kind and to worshiping and that
this belief in a higher power.
If it it,
it,
it empowers people to think this way and
it gives people a motivation to be kind.
And it would be nice if there was a
secular option like that.
That is decentralized.
It's not run by one person who winds up
banging everybody's wife and taken all
the money because that's what happens.
Always happens.
You can set your clock by these guys.
It's unbelievable.
The humanist movement is something like
that.
What is this?
I'm not aware of secular humanist or
just humanists.
There's groups all over the world have
churches.
Well,
they have meeting places,
I would call them churches,
uh,
more broadly.
The kind of universalist unitarian
church is a church and it's a religion,
but they're pretty secular.
They're like secular Jews,
you know,
they believe in the culture and the,
and the ceremonies and the rituals.
I've been to a number of these humanist
and universalist unitarian churches
ceremonies.
They light candles.
They sing hymns to Newton.
Uh,
they have testimonials about how I lost
my religion.
And to me,
I didn't really like it that much
because I was never crazy about church
in the first place,
but a lot of people clearly get value
out of this atheists and humanists that
don't believe in God.
The gathering together once a week and
being with fellow likeminded people that
has a lot of psychological value.
It connects people and that's one of the
great things about community centers in
neighborhoods,
you know,
it just connects people and like,
hey,
we're all in this together.
All right,
Bob,
see you tomorrow.
Bye Mary social capital.
There's something,
there's something great about that with
Church that uh,
I mean I was having this conversation
with bill burr about this recently.
We were talking
about it and he's like,
I don't really want to go to church,
but I think there's some,
something to that to go into a place and
putting your faith in all the people
around you and the,
the,
the higher values and morals and ethics
that you're all agreeing to,
right?
Yup.
You know,
it's back to the self help thing is sort
of a reminder every week.
Be a good person.
Don't forget to donate to charity.
Here's some local charities here.
These are our causes.
Be Good,
be good,
be nice to your spouse and your children
is on.
And so people kind of leave a little
charged up for the week on Sunday,
back to Monday.
And that's probably the main draw of
those big Tony Robbins things too.
There's a community of us together.
We're all trying to do better.
We're all trying to better ourselves and
optimize our lives.
That's right.
There's nothing wrong with it.
Same thing.
Back to Jordan Peterson.
That's the threat.
He's,
he's given a message.
People like to hear that.
Yeah.
And okay.
So what,
why is that bad?
It's not bad.
Yeah.
Now of course people like Richard
Dawkins will point out,
yeah,
but,
but can we decouple all the supernatural
nonsense from the social community?
Yes,
we can.
But don't you think that there's less,
there's less of an acceptance of the
supernatural nonsense than there was 50
years ago,
100 years ago.
And it seems to be a trend.
Those members are getting bad.
Secularism.
The number of the percentage of nones,
people tick the box for no religious
affiliation,
uh,
that used to be in the single digits.
It's now 25 percent of all Americans.
Thirty three percent of millennials.
Those born after 1991.
And it looks like probably with
identities can be closer to 50 percent
people born after 1995.
Now they're not necessarily atheists,
agnostics,
skeptics,
but they don't affiliate with any
religion.
And that's good because in the sense
that,
uh,
it's religious behavior that causes some
of these social problems that we are
encountering now with Islam.
For example.
Um,
you know,
so if somebody privately believes in God
or whatever and they don't act on it,
okay,
I guess I don't care.
And that's it.
It's the acting on your beliefs that
causes the problem.
Well,
when you enforce those beliefs on other
people,
that's right.
So when it spills over into politics,
education,
science education,
particular,
well,
that's one of the real problems they're
having in Europe when they're dealing
with people that are coming over from
other countries where they have a
different set of values and they're
seeing women in skirts and they're
calling them whores,
bro.
You're in England,
right?
Different set of rules over here in
California.
You won't believe it.
And they think that God has,
you know,
God has dictated these rules are in
their eyes.
They're seeing some horrible sin.
They're seeing the decay of the moral
fiber,
the moral fiber of their environment.
These are primitive beliefs having to do
with men wanting to control women's
reproductive rights.
There's evolutionary reasons for this.
You had Brett and heather on here.
They get explained that beautifully,
um,
at.
But we have to overcome that just
because it's an evolved tendency for men
to want to control women's reproduction
a doesn't mean we should do that.
The opposite.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
so I make the case,
one of my scientific American columns on
abortion that,
you know,
if our mutual goal between pro lifers
and protracer is,
is to reduce the amount of abortions we,
we know the formula,
educate women,
empower women versus control,
birth control,
access to birth control,
and so on.
It just happens automatically.
The pregnancy rates go down,
therefore abortion rates are going to go
down.
We know how this,
uh,
do this,
but still people that pro lifers,
you know,
to start a glom on to it,
but it's a moral issue.
Okay?
Take the moral out of it.
I understand it's a human life or
potential human,
the whatever you want to argue.
I get on the.
Take that out.
Let's just work to the common goal of
reducing the number of unwanted
pregnancies.
My favorite one that still exists is
abstinence.
The idea that they're trying to push
this on these.
Essentially when you.
Especially we're talking about really
young people that are just getting horny
for the first time.
Yeah,
I mean they're on drugs.
Just say no,
why are you talking about you take the
average 17,
18 year old kids and you try to get them
together and no one's in the room and
they're aging raging with hormones and
they're both supposed to keep their
clothes on like,
look,
man,
it's not going to happen.
It's just not going to happen.
You've got to let that go and this idea
that you're going to tell them that God
wants them to be abstinent like,
are you sure?
Why did he give us these goddamn
hormones?
What's happening here?
There studies on how effective
abstinence only programs or chastity
pledges and these sorts of things,
how effective.
Not only are they not effective,
they're worse because then people go
into like a date or something,
unprepared band,
the hormones kick in and they start
going at it and then they don't have
protection.
Well,
there's also the thing where
Catholic schools,
like when I was a kid,
we always knew and like this is what
we're talking about in the eighties,
everyone knew the girls who went to all
girls,
Catholic schools were freaks because
they were never around boys because
they're all in just this school with
girls with they end there.
Everything is suppression.
Suppress,
suppress,
suppress.
They just can't wait to get out there.
They find a boy and they go crazy.
Like everybody knew it.
I mean,
this is not something that I knew as a
comedian or as a person who studies
culture.
This is something I knew as a 14 year
old.
Everyone knew that girls who went to all
school,
all girl Catholic schools were freaks,
right?
It's just as the opposite intended
effect.
There was a study,
a British study I found that found some
small part.
It was like one and a half percent or
whatever of 10,000 women who said they
got pregnant without having sex.
Oh,
that happened.
It happened.
How did that happen?
It doesn't happen.
So immaculate conception.
That's right.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
Or they do everything but.
Or they had anal or whatever and say,
well,
we didn't actually have sex,
you know,
like Clinton,
you know.
Well,
what do you mean by sex?
And have sexual as soon as he
will.
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman is landscape.
Sex is intercourse,
penis,
Vagina.
That's it.
Everything else is just hanging out.
Right?
Well,
it's the,
the,
the need for belief systems is.
It's so.
I mean,
it,
it helps people to have belief systems.
If they're positive and they're
objective and their well-reasoned in
there,
you know,
these are backed by facts and knowledge.
It helps,
but the need for belief systems is so
strong that will take a belief system
that's wonky because.
Because we,
we have that desire.
Yup.
Yeah.
The brain abhors a vacuum of belief is
the way I put it in and something's
going to be in there.
So let's try to put in those brains
rational science based values,
and we had those,
I mean,
humanist values that,
you know,
the humanist movement is now about a,
sent almost a century old universal
human rights.
Uh,
the,
the Universal Human Rights Declaration
just celebrated its 50th anniversary.
You can get diverse.
People do agree.
Uh,
you don't have to have the correct
philosophical arguments to get there,
but you know,
just everybody should be treated equally
under the law.
Can we at least agree on that?
Yes.
Okay.
Uh,
I mean,
if you start off with pinker makes this
point lightened manal.
If you start off with Jesus died for our
sins,
that's the most important value built
value to me.
You're not going to get agreement in a
room full of,
you know,
UN diversity.
You got to start with something super
basic and general.
Everybody's deserves equal rights.
Okay?
Yep.
And then you start to build from there
and we can do that.
Do you find you've been in this for a
long time and you've done some really
valuable work?
It's been,
it's,
it's so nice that there's someone like
you that really has dedicated their life
to really illuminating truth,
exposing all the flaws and people's
thinking.
Do you feel like the reception of this
is you're,
it's easier now or there's momentum
behind this kind of thinking?
I do,
yeah,
for sure.
It's more open Po,
po part of my.
I have a distorted view.
I'm from California.
I grew up in southern California.
We're pretty liberal society here,
so I'm empathetic to people that write
me from Oklahoma or Arkansas and I'm in
this little town.
Everybody.
The only question is which Christian
church do you go to the Baptist or the
presbytarian and you know,
everyone in his family,
everyone at work is a believer and he's
an atheist.
A.
Okay.
So I haven't faced anything like that,
you know,
and I'm a middle aged white guy,
I don't.
I do have white privileges.
I know.
Uh,
and so I,
I am sympathetic to others,
but I do think across the board things
are more tolerant.
You know,
we know this from studies on interracial
marriage,
for example.
That's not even an issue anymore.
The gay rights thing has changed very
rapidly.
I mean,
that was stunning.
How quickly social attitudes changed
after the.
Well,
we have to remember in 2:13,
Hillary Clinton was still saying that
she didn't believe in gay marriage.
Is there any standout because it was a
political position.
That's right now Obama in 2011,
although you never know when a
politician says live of course.
Uh,
but now,
uh,
so I predict,
you know,
like the gay marriage thing,
this no one will even be talking about
it in another year or two.
It'll change so quickly and so across
the board,
the acceptance now of atheist,
humanist,
secularists,
agnostics,
whatever is become much,
much better in most places.
They're still set,
of course,
Islamic countries where not only would
they burn me and you,
they'd burned Catholics because they
picked the wrong religion.
So there's still that.
But I wonder if there's some improvement
there in those countries because the
Internet with younger people when
they're being exposed to these new
ideas,
maybe a,
I'm not sure on that data.
The last time I saw a big pole was on,
uh,
how supportive you would be of Sharia
Law and these are pretty scary,
like a third to a half of Muslims living
in Muslim countries that they would
support Sharia law.
And if you look at Tria laws,
as you know,
it's,
it's pretty scary for very anti
democratic liberal attitudes about
rights and women and things like that.
So there,
I think the prediction would be yes,
a millennials and igeneration when they
get into power than maybe not just
political power,
but like controlling talk shows,
radio shows,
tv shows,
scripts,
things like that.
Most,
I think most moral change happens in
people's minds from inculcating it from
culture pop culture of just how you talk
about other people.
I'm like,
if Dawkins makes this point that you can
tell pretty much down to the decade,
uh,
when a book was written by the way they
talk about when like a novel talk about
women or blacks or whatever going back,
say a century,
you can say,
well that was 19 thirties the way
they're talking about Jews.
And that's the kind of thing that shifts
very slowly,
you hardly notice it,
but from people like you comedians,
you tell certain jokes or you say
certain things and it becomes more
acceptable scripts for television shows
and films and all of us kind of watch it
and absorb it and just think,
yeah,
you know,
we shouldn't be saying those kinds of
things about women and Jews and blacks
or whatever.
Stopped doing that and that consciously
you just kind of soak it in.
So I think you still need laws.
We have to sometimes change the law and
just say,
okay,
it's now illegal to discriminate against
Jews or whatever.
You can't do that now.
People may still want to do that.
How do we change their thinking?
Well,
if that's the bottom of thing that takes
the course of decades or maybe a century
and it takes generations sometimes
because the new young kids have to see
the flaws in the way their parents are
thinking and,
and,
and have access to this information and
form their own opinions on these things.
Hopefully bakes based on objective
reasoning and reality and and all the
awesome stuff that's available now.
My stepdad was in the Pacific war and
the way he talked about Japanese,
you know,
when I was a kid and the 60th and then
by the time I became an adult,
I'm like,
Dad,
you don't,
don't say the stuff.
Don't say it out loud.
And think about 1947 to 1960.
That's a tiny period of time.
Right?
It's so sure.
Yeah.
I mean that's really like,
you know,
when we're talking about the early two
thousands,
right?
Imagine if World War Two happened during
the early two thousands.
Yeah.
It's hard.
It's hard to remember.
It's hard to put it into perspective.
I think pop culture,
the media,
social media and so on is,
is going to accelerate moral progress.
It'll happen faster.
Like it happened faster for women than
it did for blacks.
It happened faster for gays and it did
for women,
you know,
maybe whatever's next animal rights or
something like this will accelerate even
more.
Maybe trans rights or something about
the push back against this idea that we
are living in the safest time ever and
that there is an absolute trend,
like pinker gets criticized about this
where people say,
no,
the world is still not safe for these
people,
for this,
for this group,
for that group,
and for you saying that the world is,
it just shows your white privilege,
white male perspective and I'm on board
with,
with Steve All across the board on these
things.
He's got the data.
It depends on the question you're
asking.
You know,
it's like if you say,
yeah,
but my life is not better.
Okay,
we're not talking about your life.
The question is,
is society getting better?
Okay.
Of course there's ups and downs and this
group is doing better than that group
and yes,
there's still some racial discrimination
there's still clearly antisemites as
we've seen recently,
but across the board,
if you take like the last 200 years,
which direction are the trend lines
going?
They're all going in the right
direction.
So again,
its scale.
The question is what's the scale we're
talking about?
So it's,
it's a little unfair to pinker to say,
well,
you're blind to that thing over.
He's not talking about that one thing
there.
He's talking about just across the
board.
Yeah,
I agree.
Listen man,
thanks for everything.
Thanks for everything you do.
Thanks for all your articles saying that
books and thanks for coming on here.
And please let people know.
Your podcast once again is called
skeptics,
Alon Science,
science,
science along.
He just got a skeptic dicom and it's
posted there and yeah,
so skeptic is still going and social
media at Michael.
Shermer is my twitter feed.
You have instagram as well?
I don't do that.
How dare you?
That's Michael Shermer one.
Oh,
do you have an idea?
I'm going to start posting as of today.
Okay.
I will.
Oh yeah,
take a photo.
I always click on yours because you
always have interesting photographs from
wherever you're at.
And it's funny.
It is kind of fun.
It's just take an extra minute or two.
Giant waste of time now.
Don't get sucked down.
I'm already wasting so much time on
twitter.
Well thank you Michael.
Appreciate it man.
Thanks for having me.